e
e e
good morning
everybody Welcome to the Boston Marathon
edition of the science technology and
energy committee meeting for April 15
we'll begin our meeting as usual by
joining representative muns as he leads
us in the pledge of
aliance
States okay we have a full agenda today
we have four public hearings this
morning on the following bills Senate
Bill 595 f relative to the rates for
poll attachments Center Bill 603
relative to telephone number and area
code
Conservation Center Bill 386 relative to
establishing a committee to study power
generation transmission distribution and
storage and Cent a bill 449 relative to
the permit issuance timeline for State
air
permits after these public hearings are
concluded we will take a lunch break and
then at 2 :00 this afternoon we will
return here for an executive session on
five bills Center Bill
303 relative to the use of renewable
energy funds by the department of energy
sent a bill 388 relative to
administrative administration of
utilities by the department of energy
cinderell 391 relative to electric grid
interconnection for certain customer
generators C A bill 451 relative to an
expedited track for certain applications
to the site evaluation committee and Sen
a bill 540 requiring the department of
energy to investigate behind the meter
and utility scale energy storage that's
our agenda for today it's a busy one so
let's get started and I'm going to open
the public hearing on Senate Bill 595 FN
and call forward Senator avard the prime
sponsor of this bill good morning
Senator and welcome thank you Mr
chairman and committee
members uh appreciate you being here
it's a beautiful day hope you had a
great
weekend if I have paint on me it's
because my wife had me doing chores my
gosh uh so I'm Senator Kevin aard from
District 12 representing nashar Awards
125 uh in Brooklyn Greenville Hollis
Mason New Ipswich and ringe and I'm
pleased to present this bill uh s SP 595
relative to the rates poll attachments
595 was unanimously voted on ought to
pass with amendment by the Senate and I
appreciate your consideration of this
bill and ask you U that you would vote
for a to pass as well 595 as amended is
an important piece of legislation and
first it aligns New Hampshire's
administrative rules relative to pole
attachment rates which uh with statute
by directing the department of energy to
do adopt formulas for use when resolving
disputes between pole attachment owning
utilities and entities like Broadband
providers and attaching their networks
to the polls secondly it it directs the
agency to develop an accelerated dispute
process resolution process as the
Federal Communications uh and National
telecommunications Information
Administration have confirmed
transparent predictability and fair pole
attachment rates and accelerated dispute
resolutions are key elements to good
infrastructure development policy that's
a
mouthful just
saying this bill is providing uh
predictability transparency and
certainty to a process that is critical
to New Hampshire's goal of universal
Broadband access the New Hampshire
legislature has done great work in
recent years adopting policies which
speed and encourage Broadband employ uh
deployment such as part two of sb88
which orders the department of energy to
adopt FCC OneTouch Make Ready rules uh
we should continue that effort by
passing 595 as
amended thank you Mr chairman and
committee
members thank you uh Senator avard
questions for the
senator representative Harrington has
one thank you chairman thank you for
taking my question Senator uh just
trying to get this straight cuz reading
the text of the bill it talks about the
department which I assume is the
Department of energy correct multiple
times but when you go to the fiscal note
it talks about the Pu so who's doing
what where can you just kind of
straighten that out for us please I'm
going to try uh yeah I know it is the Pu
I think it's uh I'm trying to find out
where um they set the rules and then uh
I think the Pu executes them I'm trying
to just read so just a followup so what
you're saying is then the the department
of energy will set the on a non
adjudicative proceeding set some rule
out and then it'll be up to the Pu to
enforce the rule I believe so yes sir
okay
and does the Pu have any authority over
non-utility attachments to polls that
I'm not sure of I I don't I do not know
about that but I know that they're most
likely if you look at the fiscal note
they're going to have to hire somebody
to right I'm just a little trying to see
how that works out but I'll just save
that question we'll have a testimony by
the department in just a few minutes so
we can get some clarification on that
Senator would you say that uh it's
basically true that what this rule what
this legislation does is it gives the
department as opposed to the commission
the responsibility for developing the
formula that's used for po attachments
is that correct okay thank you further
questions for Senator avard
representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman hello Senator good morning um
so following up on representative
Harrington's question yeah uh so the doe
would set the rules and the PO pu would
enforce this seems the reverse of what
normally happens doesn't the Pu usually
set rules and the doe enforce I'm just a
pretty
face you're right
are
questions seeing none we want to thank
you senator for being here to introduce
this legislation thank you now let's
hear from the
Department Amanda Nunan and David
shulock will give us their perspective
and correct any misperceptions we may
have about this legislation good morning
to the both of you and welcome good
morning good morning
um so I want to address first the
question from representative hering
sorry thank you for represent from
representative Harrington about the
fiscal note um the bill before you has
been amended since this fiscal note was
developed by the Public Utilities
Commission and we understand from them
that this would no longer be an accurate
fiscal note I don't have an explanation
for you as to why they haven't updated
the FIS note but we do understand that
this fiscal note is no longer accurate
and that the commission would no longer
need the resources that it listed in its
fiscal note um as was noted some of this
work has transferred to the department
to um have a stakeholder session and
develop a formula for um poll attachment
resolving disputes between carriers
about the appropriate rate for a poll
attachment and uh present those to the
commission for them to adopt rules um
and it is uh currently typical that the
department would set rules under policy
and if there were sanctions and
enforcement actions to be taken that
would be done by the commission so
that's that's not a flip it's it's the
current
Paradigm um having said all of that the
department is neutral on this bill this
is work that we can do within um our our
current resources um and we're happy to
to help res Sol this
issue I think there was a question about
non-utility attachments to polls and I
don't know if Mr yes representative
Harrington repeat your question about
sorry that issue my uh my question was
on whether I obviously for the the
electric utilities the Pu and doe both
have some kind of shared authority over
that but for communication lines that
are not utilities does the do either of
those groups have the authority to tell
those entities how to operate and with
deal with poll
attachments I know the FCC has some
Authority but I didn't know that the
state did we do have some limited
Authority yes but um it's mostly
exercised through the poll
owners and their agreements follow up so
in other words the uh in this case it
would be either the I guess the
telephone company or the electric
company that owns the pole and they
would have agreements with the
Communication company and that's how the
doe and pu would have some limited
Authority that's that's how the whole
Paradigm is set up uh the Agreements are
for the most part voluntary between pole
owners and
attachers okay so this wouldn't change
that then uh no
this this doesn't really change that
Paradigm the formula would be applied
when there's a disagreement when um
parties can't come to an agreement on
what the price for an attachment should
be uh and the Pu has to set in uh step
into set rates uh they would use the
formula to do that rather than a
six-part test that they're currently
using Okay followup followup I'm just a
little concerned
because I know the FCC has control over
the like the a cable line or an internet
line line but I didn't think that the
state had the authority and unless we're
granting him via this bill to come in
and say okay this is what you're going
to charge based on this law we we we do
have that Authority we you okay you do
okay thank you Vice chair Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question uh for
clarification at least for me anyway uh
in the early part of the bill it uh
talks about uh that they the commission
shall use an a poll attachment
formula rather than a multi-part test
could could you describe the difference
between the two why one versus the
other so I don't have the current uh six
part consideration for the pole
attachment rates in front of me right
now but it's more than just a
calculation of space on the poll and
rate of return and so forth it's it's
more than just the calculation of the
rate there are other less quantifiable
factors in that six-part test and so
moving to just a formula based pole
attachment rate provides certainty to
pole
attachers follow up okay so in other
words the current system is this
multi-part
test that's correct okay thank
you further
questions representative McGee has
one good morning nice to see you all
again again um so it it appears that
there's a you know a couple of different
um intents for the bill and I'm
wondering what the timing uh says around
us meeting Our obligation to the folks
that are looking for this is the 18
months a reasonable amount of time to
get um to be setting how we're going to
move forward and finalizing the formula
because I think one of the intents here
is to create some predictability and
also to clarify that everyone who's
attached is receiving similar treatment
I guess is is that an
accurate assessment yes yes that's an
accurate summary of of what it would do
um we're comfortable with the amount of
time that the department would have to
accomplish what it needs to
accomplish and in followup followup uh
and I I understand that we've got other
bills where 18 months is also a year and
a half is also the the time frame but I
guess what I'm asking is whether there
is any sense of urgency or whether there
is uh a need for any more expedient
response to turning around um the rul
making whether the delays are actually
causing any problems for the people who
are current poll
attaches so I I'm sure you'll hear a
testimony from some of the current poll
attaches this morning um my
understanding of as Mr shellock
identified earlier the current structure
is there are voluntary agreements
agreements entered into negotiated
between the PO attacher and a pole owner
this would be for when those entities
can't come to an agreed upon solution so
I'll let them comment on whether there's
any timing issues or sense of urgency
for them oh can it follow up okay so is
what you're saying that um there may be
agreements that the uh poll owners and
the Pol attaches can come to outside of
this process that can continue to go
forward yes and there would not be a
delay waiting on this correct that's
correct thanks I thought that's what you
were saying representative Ms has a
question thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you for being here this morning um I
have heard conflicting opinions as to
whether or not um this bill would bring
us more in line with the um the approach
recommended or preferred by the
FCC um can you touch on
that certainly um as drafted the
department would give deference to the
formulas that the FCC has developed for
pole attachment
rates as I indicated this would be used
when parties weren't able to come to a
negotiated agreement um but it would
bring in those instances the pole
attachment rate more in line with the
FCC formulas
certainly
followup um and and then also it it it's
um it's unclear to me how New
Hampshire's rates pole attachment rates
compared to other states I mean I've
again I've heard that they're in some
they're higher they're lower do you have
any sense as to how our rates compared
to Maine Vermont
Massachusetts I don't have any of that
information with me today it's certainly
information if you're interested in we
could go back and um collect and provide
to you if you'd
like representative Kaplan has a
question thank you thank you Mr chair
and thank you for coming in this morning
um just for a little bit more clarity on
the formula it does say that you will
give deference to the FCC formula but
you may consider other formulas so what
what other form you know what type of
other form would that be from other
state formulas or how would they differ
from the FCC thank
you so that's that's a little bit of a
chicken in the egg question I think
until we have a stakeholder session and
hear input from the various stakeholders
involved in the poll attachment process
um I I can't really point to uh another
um another formula that might be
considered
I'm I'm sure we'll hear from other
folks yes I believe some of our electric
utilities have a formula that they use
in determining what the pole attachment
rate is for pole attachers so that may
be a proposal that gets put forward um
and considered in conjunction with the
current FCC poll attachment
rate we can find out more about that
later uh Mr LCA from ever Source will be
testifying representative muns thank you
Mr chair just as a kind of another
followup to my my question about the
rates and how they compare um has there
been any analysis done to indicate what
you know adopting a a more FCC compliant
formula would do
to
um um elect rates cable rates um I mean
presumably it would change how much the
attachers pay which ultimately is going
to get passed through to Consumers has
any analysis like that been
done this is just the very beginning
process for this so at this point no um
we we haven't looked at what that would
be uh this formula would be for use in
instances when a poll owner and a poll
attacher can't voluntarily agree upon a
poll attachment rate so to the extent
those Agreements are in place now they
go forward to the extent they can
negotiate and agree to rate as they've
done in the past that would occur this
would be used when there's a dispute
about what the poll attachment rate
should
be okay seeing no further questions we
want to thank uh from the Department for
being here now we'll get a perspective
from the industry and I'll call on Paul
Phillips of the New Hampshire telephone
Association and I think he'll be joined
by Chris Rand of Granit State
Communications and they will give us
their perspective on this legislation
good morning gentlemen thank you good
morning Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee uh my name is
Paul Phillips I'm an attorney with
primer Piper Egleston and Kramer I live
in Plymouth New Hampshire I practice law
in Manchester New Hampshire and I
represent the New Hampshire telephone
Association I've been their regulatory
Council for approximately 20 years
including representing them in uh two uh
poll attachment rulle makings before the
Pu one in
2008 uh which adopted the chapter 1300
rules and one in 2017 which amended
those rules to um acknowledge and
accommodate dat the uh FCC poll
attachment formula uh we are here uh to
oppose s SP
595 I'm joined by Chris Rand who is an
owner and officer at Grant EST State
Communications and I'll let Chris start
things
off good morning uh Chris ran Granite
State Communications I'm the vice
president uh and Granite State
Communications uh is a broadband and
voice provider uh we provide fiber to
the home and Business Services in eight
communities uh across Southern New
Hampshire from Washington uh down to
Sandow um I'm here uh on behalf of New
Hampshire telephone
Association uh nhta
Members Own polls or share ownership
with electric
companies um we feel that the FCC
formula is already generous to attachers
in the case of gr State Communications
um the attachers are only paying a few
dollars per year to attach to our polls
um we we understand Broadband has become
uh a very competitive service to
provide and we're concerned that this
bill would allow the attachers uh to
bring us in front of the FCC in an
attempt merely to shift their cost of
attaching onto our
customers um for NH ta members renting
space to attachers is not a lucrative
line of business it often costs uh uh
more than the revenue that's
generated uh and the nhta members see
this
legislation as a reaction to a contract
dispute uh between a single pole owner
and a single
attacher we don't see any benefit to an
expensive and protracted regul at
process the agreements that were
mentioned earlier are private agreements
they're voluntarily entered into between
two parties uh any contract dispute can
be resolved via the terms of that
agreement or the existing regulatory
processes as they are um and we don't
see that it's necessary to uh pull in
all the pole owners across the state of
New Hampshire uh when it's a dispute
between two parties
uh and that's it thanks Chris uh the
nhta companies uh have not had occasion
to come to the legislature for quite a
few years because in 2012 as you know uh
the legislature enacted s sp48 which
effectively
deregulated uh telecommunications in in
most areas uh one area that was not
deregulated was pole attachments and so
I that's why we find ourselves before
you today but nht's view of that is that
the existing uh uh mechanism for
resolving pole attachment agreements and
pole attachment disputes is working well
um and this legislation is effectively a
form of
re-regulation which will uh create more
regulatory uh headaches and problems for
companies like the NHA companies uh the
current system is that uh the Pu rules
strongly favor private contracts uh
these are sophistic ated parties they uh
engage in arms length negotiations they
represent their interests well and they
reach agreements on the attachments uh
where they can't uh reach an agreement
or or where an existing agreement uh
falls short they can go to the Pu and
they can present their uh facts their
evidence and they can have a case
specific uh adjudication and and
assignment of rates uh from the Pu based
on this on the facts of the parties that
are before them what this legislation
does is turn that on its head starts out
with a state um mandated Formula One
siiz fits-all formula for all owners and
attachers uh and uh it effectively uh
negates or nullifies those contracts
because you'll know as you are entering
into that contract that there's a state
formula out there and if your
calculation shows that you're better off
under the formula then you are under a
contract then you'll go straight to the
Pu and say please oppose please impose
this formula so it will uh it will uh uh
injure and and harm that arms length
negotiation process for those private
contracts it will unbalance that
negotiation um and in our view that's uh
a waste of time and and resources uh we
think the legislation uh creates a lot
of open-ended questions
um there are um cases around the country
where State imposed uh pole rates have
been found to be a a constitutional
violation of the taking Clause uh New
Hampshire and New England have not gone
that route yet uh but at the same time
we've not had a state uh mandated
formula for pole rates so far so that
would be one piece of uh litigation that
we might see coming down the road uh so
uh we think that the proper course for
the house would be to uh send this bill
to interim study uh we think that it
would be wise to explore some of the
implications of the legislation uh and
understand uh the real impacts uh before
you take it up again so thank you we're
happy to answer any
questions thank you I have a question
for you I heard the department stay
earlier that this formula once it's
developed would only be used in the case
where where two parties couldn't agree
to a contract it would be a kind of a
fallback
position but if I understood your
testimony correctly you're saying that
this formula would become the standard
would become the default that everyone
would use it would not be a fallback is
that your position I think that's
clearly the intent of the legislation if
you look at the existing pu rules and
the six factors uh that Miss Nunan was
referring to earlier in her testimony
one of those factors is the FCC formula
so when you have a a just under a poll
contract and you take it to the Pu uh
the puc is supposed to set rates for
those two parties and one of the factors
they consider is the fcc's formula so
you have an opportunity to uh present
your facts and your economic situation
and for small companies like nhta you
know they may have higher costs they may
have different factors uh but the FCC
formula under the pu's rules has become
the driving force in those discussions
in SB
595 you you start with the formula right
the state develops the formula first uh
and then you have that hanging out there
so that as you're entering into your
private negotiations you know that if if
you uh if you're looking at this
contract you know what the rate that the
state wants already is and it's it's uh
fairly guaranteed if you take that
dispute to the Pu at that point they're
going to they're going to adopt or
they're going to impose that formula on
your on your situation so if you if it
favors you that's great if it doesn't
favor you you know then you're kind of
stuck so you're basically saying that
the existence of the formula would
preclude good faith negotiations between
two parties to to come up with a
contract we think it would effectively
hinder and hamper those negotiations
right I mean you've got a state formula
that's been developed in a non-
adjudicative proceeding it's not based
on you know evidence and facts it's
based on
um you know other other factors um and
it's going to be hanging out there as
kind of the you know the
albatross you mentioned earlier that
this legislation would create quote
headaches headaches and problems quote
for you the members of your Association
could you put some meat on that bone and
tell me what kind of headaches and what
kind of problems you're talking about
well sure yeah the um I mean we we think
there are a number of open questions
um one is what is the effective
enforceability of existing pole
contracts if this legislation passes
because you really can't uh defend a
pole
contract uh that is going to be that's
going to have rates that are you know in
in conflict or in contrast with this
state formula so how do you effectively
enforce this contract knowing that as
you're going into the Pu this formula is
going to drive drive the discussion so
you know you have contracts you think
they're valid but are they enforceable
um is there going to be any meaningful
process left for adjudicating these
contractual disputes uh the intention
seems to be that the formula will um
streamline that process but the you know
the simple fact of the matter is that if
you don't have any facts to to argue
about as you go into an adjudication
what's the purpose of
adjudicating
um we um as you as you may know um and I
think it was alluded to earlier uh pole
attachments under federal law fall
primarily within the jurisdiction of the
FCC uh unless a state has certified to
the FCC that it has an effective and
fair regulatory scheme on the state
level and the Pu in January of 2008 uh
certified uh to that fact uh to the FCC
uh the FCC rules require that there be a
timely adjudication of dispute
and we believe that this throws the
adjudication process well I won't say
out the window but into some question
and so we have some concerns about uh
whether this uh statute would continue
to comply with FCC standards and whether
the 2008 certification would remain uh
effective so that's that's another issue
that we have um so I I'll I'll stop
there we have a number of questions okay
uh representative has a question thank
you Mr chairman he can tell when I'm
chomping at the bit in a row of
questions um okay so my question is from
as I'm listening to you speak what is
striking me is that you're here sort of
advocating for um companies who own
polls that are not the utilities not the
Monopoly utilities right so there's a
there's a market where polls are owned
by different individuals and um and this
is it correct to assume that this might
disadvantage those smaller pole owners
with this burdensome regulation than it
would for sort of the larger folks who
um you know they're marketing this bill
to us as providing
predictability um well our concern is
for the smaller companies like granted
State like dun Barton
telephone um like Bretton Wood's
telephone uh that don't have uh
substantial customer bases and and uh
you know their their polls are one of
their main assets uh and under the
present system you know if there's a
dispute about the poll attachment rates
uh you know either the attacher or the
owner can take that case to the Pu and
have the merits of that case heard based
on the you know the facts and the
circumstances of those parties uh and
that seems to be what is trying to be
avoided with this legislation is not to
have case specific fact specific uh uh
resolutions of disputes it seems to be a
one siiz fits-all one state One Rate
type of uh solution and that is going to
uh uh burden smaller companies thanks
representative Vice chair Thomas has a
question uh thank you Mr chair thank you
for Tak that question and um pardon if I
don't fully understand this but would
this bill
is there any effect either positive or
negative or maybe or maybe no effect on
this bill in terms of how polls would be
replaced or the timing or how fast they
would would be replaced if they were had
to be replaced or repaired would this
bill hamper that process any way or have
no relation to that well there there is
a relationship I I think we'd have to
see what the formula is once it's
developed by by the doe uh we don't know
based on the statute you know which
which factors are going to go into it I
mean what we're what we're hearing is
that they want to bring it closer into
alignment with the FCC formula um but
the legislation doesn't say we're just
adopting the FCC formula they say
there's going to be a number of other
factors they're going to look at other
things that are not currently in the
rules so the purpose of a formula at
least from the fcc's perspective is to
take into account all the costs that the
pole owner uh bears in terms of
deploying those poles and M maintaining
those poles as well as the uh costs that
the attacher brings to the situation
when they attach their facilities to the
polls and all those cost factors are
supposed to be put into a formula and
generate a fair and Equitable rate that
everybody can agree to that reflects the
appropriate apportionment of those
costs uh I don't see that language in
the statud I mean I think there's a an
expression of intent about that but we
don't quite know what the formula is is
to be at the end of the
day followup uh thank you and um I'll
ask the question differently I think I
understood your answer but in terms of
as as you might know we've had issues in
the state with polls not being removed
that have been sitting there for maybe
times sometimes years uh because of who
owns the pole how expensive to take it
away whatever would the current process
we're under now um be better in terms of
uh getting those polls issues resolved
or would the new process speed up the
removal and replacement of Old
Poles well right so there's nothing in
the statute that that speaks of the
actual uh M maintain maintenance and and
replacement of poles uh it seems evident
on the face of the statute that the
intent is to reduce the revenues uh if
you will for the poll owners uh which
means that they will have less Revenue
than available for things like pole
maintenance I mean I will just say I'm
not suggesting that my clients are not
going to maintain their polls they do a
great job I don't believe they have the
issues that you're describing which uh
May afflict some of the larger companies
um but you know it is ultimately a a
cost versus Revenue effect and the the
idea here is to reduce revenues for the
owners representative Kennedy has a
question thank you Mr chairman and
thanks for taking my question uh you've
explained pretty well how this might
harm some small companies could could
you give a simple explanation of how uh
this might lead to higher cost for rate
payers well sure I mean as as Chris's
testimony suggested this is essentially
a resolution of a of a contract dispute
between an attacher and a pole owner and
the attacher uh didn't like the outcome
of the adjudication and so they're
looking for a legislative uh fix to that
but the idea is that um the attacher
wants to pay
less obviously the owner is going to get
going to get
less um and that's going to uh those
those revenues are going to be lost um
these are these are pole owning
utilities right they're either telephone
companies or electric companies or both
and they are serving
customers uh all across New Hampshire
and if they are not getting revenues
from attachers they're going to have to
make up those revenues elsewhere um the
nhta companies as I said in 2008 uh
stopped being rate regulated so there's
no longer uh you know an immediate uh
pass through to the rate payers so
they'll have my clients will have to
take account of those lost revenues and
figure out what the best uh solution is
but if they were rate regulated they
might well just pass those lost revenues
on to their rate
payers
followup yeah so I see that as a as a
matter of fairness but um you know could
that lead to you know increase in
charges by the companies that own the
polls and a decrease in Chargers by the
company that is supplying you know the
service or whatever it is they're
attaching uh if I understand your
question you're asking whether there
might be some gaming of rates in play
here between competing providers and and
we we think there may be some of that I
mean I don't want to impune anybody's
motivations but uh that at least in
terms of the uh the way this legis ation
came out of a uh of an adjudicative
process at the Pu we think there might
be some of that going on you want to
speak to that Chris no I think you I
think you said it very well
representative CL has a
question thank you chair thank you for
taking my question
um not following this through the
Senate one of my questions I will go
with this one since it can be
adjudicated through the PC
PCU uh what percent in the last couple
years have gone that route that caused
this legislation to come before
us uh very very few I mean it really is
an aberrational case um to to have a a
poll rate adjudication at the Pu the
system I mean this is this is the uh
whole purpose of the Pu rule if you read
the existing rule there's a very heavy
emphasis on private contracts and that's
been in place for you know many many
years and the system is working well
there there are very few disputes that
reach the
Pu representative Harrington has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question I you had
mentioned about um cost shifting so
other than the cost that we are pretty
familiar with which would be property
taxes paid on the polls what costs are
associated with your poll having
somebody else's communication line on
it you want to speak to that
Chris the the polls themselves obviously
have a a life to them uh and there that
the cost of that is spread over many
years essentially the formula entertains
what it is what the costs the inputs are
um to come up with that poll attachment
rate and if there's a process at the Pu
which in some cases May artificially
reduce that attachment rate then those
costs would simply have to be pushed
somewhere else okay follow up follow up
yeah when I'm let's let's forget about
the Pu and all the government stuff
let's just talk about your company you
have a poll out there you run your I
assume a telephone line on it um maybe
there's an electric line on it maybe
there's a cable line on it maybe there's
a internet line on it how how those T
other than your line what cost do you
incur by having those other attached to
your pole the the taxes and just the
ongoing expenses which may include uh
ice and snow pulling those lines down uh
routine maintenance um requiring the
cost of replacement of the pole Etc okay
one more question but you don't replace
the in other words if you let's use this
the regretful the last month we've had a
large number of polls come down all
across the
state if uh you have your poll and it
and it comes
down um I'm just trying to get assess
the cost so if it hits somebody else's
line and that causes the pole to snap
then you are stuck with replacing the
cost of the pole regardless of why it
came down that's correct most of the for
Grant State Communications most of the
polls that we own we we share with
eversource there are some cases where we
have solely owned poles and then where
we rent space from other uh pole owners
but the vast majority of them are owned
by uh in our areas are owned by half are
owned by us and the other half of the
poll is owned by ever Source we share
that ownership so the more
attachments we bear the the cost of
replacing that pole okay representative
hering here and other people would like
to ask questions too representative
parshall has a
question thank you chair and thank you
for being here today in 2013 the public
aties commission uh did devise a formula
that um is sometimes applied in these
cases I believe did that result in a uh
closing down of negotiation in any way
when according to your scenario um of
how um this could be detrimental to
negotiation did that have an effect on
uh it's a great question and um I I've
only read the decisions I've not been
involved in any of those adjudications
because uh the nhda companies have not
had uh occasion to have those disputes
but the way that the system works now is
that you if if you're an grieved
attacher or an agreed poll owner you
take the case to the
Pu uh and one of the factors they
consider is this FCC formula the FCC
formula certainly drives the discussion
um but the Pu is able Within in those
case specific adjudications to take
account of other factors that are unique
or or specific to the individual parties
so the formula does uh weigh heavily in
the
discussions uh followup please followup
and it's your belief that a a formula to
replace the existing formula would not
be as uh uh moldable me um meltable as
far as um allowing those negotiations
that we do want to have happen
right now I think my point was that uh
well first of all we don't know what the
formula will be because it still needs
to be defined and and the factors that
are listed in the statute are different
from those that are in the the rule
right now uh but I think my My overall
point was that uh knowing that there's
this formula out there that is is
blessed by the state right it's been
blessed by the doe and the Pu and that
they know that they're going to use it
uh you know Faithfully in every every
dispute um creates you know it it it
sways the discussion it will it tilts
tilts the balance if you will in the in
those negotiations representative
Bernardi has a
question thank you Mr chair um so as I'm
listening to this it seems that the
driver of your uh position comes from
the belief that a uh formula is going to
give end up giving the companies less
Revenue than they currently uh have
available to them or put them in a worse
position in any kind of
negotiation
so do you have the ability to make the
case in the discussions with the setting
of the formula that's going to be
adopted to present a position that will
influence a a formula that's going to
take care of you from a from a a cost
perspective
I mean I I I expect we will take part in
I mean if if the legislation passes
we'll take part in that non adjudicative
proceeding uh a non- adjudicative
proceeding is different from an
adjudication because it's not uh based
on specific facts that apply to specific
parties it's based on larger policy
questions and the p and the doe in this
case will take account of all the
comments but they're not strictly Bound
by evidentiary rules or evidentiary
standards they don't have to
you know adjudicate a particular dispute
so I mean we U we'll we'll take part if
that's the case and we'll make our best
pitch um I think our concern is that uh
we only get the one shot so if if we uh
if the P if the doe doesn't doesn't
believe us on that day uh we're we're
stuck until the next uh non-
adjudicative
rulemaking followup Are there specific
criteria that you think would be uh
important
for uh the uh doe to examine and in
internalize into the eventual formula
that will would would arise from this
that would put the companies in a
position that then is acceptable to
them I mean I I think that we haven't
obviously discussed this but I think the
the um argument we would make is we'd
like to see some dis differentiation in
the eventual rule for smaller companies
um with uh different uh cost criteria so
we we'd want to see some ability to
distinguish uh smaller from larger and
local from National and you know all
that stuff uh in terms of uh the impact
of the
rule okay members I would like you to
consider holding your f f further
questions for future testifiers we have
four more people who would like to
testify additional perspectives we'd
like here thank you so thank you
gentlemen for being here I've heard
mentioned a couple of times now effect
on rate payers well if there is anybody
in this room who can uh tell us more
about the effect on rate
payers other than our consumer Advocate
I don't know who that would be so I'd
like to call next on our consumer
Advocate the rate payer Watchdog Donald
cre to give us his P perspective on this
legislation uh thank thank thank you
chairman Vose and good morning to you
and to members of the committee uh as
you all know I'm Donald Cree the uh
consumer Advocate my job by Statute is
to Advocate on behalf of the state's
residential utility customers and uh my
testifying today might be an example of
fools rushing in Where Angels Fear To
Tread in that I am not an expert on poll
attachment uh and the rules that are
applicable there too uh so I don't have
a lot to say about this bill my
recommend recation to you is identical
to the one you just heard from Mr
Phillips which is to consign this bill
to interim study and here's why and
really Representatives Kennedy and muns
have already made my case for me uh the
cost of maintaining a network of utility
polls is a zero sum game the companies
that own polls are going to recover
their costs from somebody one way or
another so if the third-party companies
that attach their facilities to a
utilities polls don't cover the costs or
to the extent that they don't cover the
costs incurred by the pole owner then
the pole owner is going to turn around
and charge its regulated rate payers
we're moving to an era in New Hampshire
where utility poles are going to be
owned by our electric distribution
companies and while I really love our
electric distribution companies none of
them are Charities all of them are going
to recover from their regulated captive
customers whatever they do not recover
from pole attachers my understanding
about this bill first of all it struck
me that the proponents of the bill who
have testified so far today don't seem
to understand the bill and its
implications which to me suggests a good
reason to send for sending this to
interim study so we can all think about
it some more and make sure that we do
the right thing Visa V rate payers
because we are as rate payers the only
wallet in the room and um the other
point I would make is that it does
indeed appear to me that what happened
here is that there was a contentious uh
poll attachment case that was pending
before the puc that the poll attacher
did not like the results of and the
result is this bill that was presented
to you I unfortunately did not testify
about this in the Senate uh my practice
these days is not to look for reasons to
testify at the state house but only to
go and appear at hearings when asked to
and I just wasn't paying attention to
pole attachments over in the other body
but I did hear about this bill from both
sides and I've come to my own
independent judgment which is I think
this bill should be consigned to interim
study that's the extent of my testimony
and of course I'd be happy to uh
entertain friendly and non-friendly
questions okay representative Kennedy
has a
question uh thank you Mr chairman thanks
for taking my question I I mean right
now it seems like the FCC has the main
body of rules the Pu can make some
adjustments and there's a private
negotiation is there anything wrong with
that system uh no this is an example I
think of cooperative federalism at work
uh back when I was General Counsel of
the Pu in 2018 or seven uh the question
came up like do we continue to allow the
FCC to do the regulating of poll
attachments or do we claw back some of
the authority because the Comm tele
Federal Telecommunications Act allow
states to do exactly what New Hampshire
did which is pass a statute saying no
our commission is going to regulate that
but the FCC does have a role it does
establish that formula it's entitled to
some respect and deference so I think
that in terms of who is best equipped to
regulate what the amount of money is
that poll attachers get it is best done
on the state level and that is in fact
what we do but the FCC does continue to
play a
role follow up so is the answer
no is the answer your question to me was
is does the existing Paradigm is it okay
and I think it is okay this bill would
tweak it in a way whose effects I think
are intended to be more costs to
electric and other rate payers of pole
owners less costs to the unregulated
companies that also need to use polls
representative Harrington asked before
about I I think his questions had to do
with what's the incremental cost if you
add another uh wire to a utility pole
and the answer is nothing essentially or
very little but that doesn't mean that
you should be able to attach your wires
to poles for free if you're a pole
attacher and you're making money by
using the uh network of polls in a
particular territory then you should pay
your fair share of those costs and if
you don't pay your fair share of those
costs the people who are going to make
up the difference are captive raid
payers that's my ultimate point
representative PL has a
question microphone
please thank you chair Mr cre thank you
for taking my question uh I'm going to
ask you a question I was going to ask
further because you mentioned a r pair
and being involved in similar contracts
like this as a small business owner I
was going to ask them the questions of
length of term and things like that
but going back to the rate
pair I'm a small business I have no
choice to look for other polls those are
the only ones in
Monopoly I had to look for a
longterm contract because I knew I was
paying too much but I needed to spread
it out and over the course everything
worked but
you're brought up a point about the
large distribution company's taking it
over they don't need to do what I did
they just passed it on and say correct I
think that that is correct
yes representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair um and thank you for
being here uh you've mentioned now in
term study and the the last group of
people also mentioned that what is it in
this bill that is worth saving or
investigating by going to interm study
and why not just kill
it well I I suppose
I I've been told that there are
inconsistencies between the way the Pu
decided the dispute over how to
compensate uh or how how much ever
should eversource should have been
allowed to pay for the polls it bought
from Consolidated which implicates a lot
of the same issues and the poll
attachment dispute that the Pu resolved
that was the subject of rehearing
motions and a lot of protracted
litigation so what I don't understand
and what I think you might also not
understand is really what the what the
best public policy is here around Fair
allocation of pole attachment costs
utility polls are very important and our
Network Industries are very important
but we have to get the cost allocations
right okay seeing no further questions
from the consumer Advocate we want to
thank you for being here thank you for
hearing my testimony great to see you
now we'll call on Mara Weston who
represents NEC ta to get her
perspective good morning Miss
Weston and Miss guer I forgot you were
gonna be there too Miss Geer
sorry good morning chairman Vose members
of the House science and technology and
energy committee for the record my name
is Mora Weston and I'm here today on
behalf of the New England connect ity
and Telecommunications
Association necta members in New
Hampshire include breez line which is
formerly Atlantic Broadband Charter
Communications and
Comcast together our members service
approximately
485,000 customers and offer their
services to more than 695,000 locations
in 185 communities joining me today is
attorney Susan Gyer as a former p
commissioner and Regulatory attorney uh
she's going to be here to help answer
your
questions necta supports Senate Bill 595
as amended and we thank doe and other
stakeholders for their efforts in
helping to craft this
legislation we believe that this is an
important clarification to existing
statute as you've heard it directs the
doe to adopt a poll attachment rate
formula using historical cost data and
it provides guidance to the doe and pu
on resolving pole attachment disputes
when and if they
arise this does not change Reliance on
pole attachment negotiations and
agreements and it also does not change
the forum for disputes from the New
Hampshire PU to the
FCC current law calls upon the doe to
develop a pole attachment formula and
additionally as you've heard the
rules contain up to six factors
including a formula that the Pu should
consider when determining whether a pole
attachment rate is unjust and
unreasonable in the event of a dispute
the process and these
factors are vague ambiguous and
amorphous they were adopted in
2007 and they were applied and tested
for the first time in
2023 the formula adopted pursuant to 595
as amended would be simpler and
transparent ensuring maximum Clarity and
predictability for all stakeholders
it is not one size fits-all it is not
rate setting it is the adoption of a
formula that would consider many inputs
and and Susan can speak to
that I want to mention that currently
evera and other utilities use formulas
very similar to the FCC formula that is
currently the practice for many
utilities so this is not a dress IC
change for that group of
utilities as I mentioned sener Bill 595
is amended would create more
predictability it directs the agency to
give difference to the
longstanding widely accepted and
judicially approved FCC formula while
allowing them flexibility to determine
what is right for New Hampshire
that formula the FCC
formula is in place in a great majority
of us States including Maine
Massachusetts Vermont and
Connecticut in fact most New Hampshire
pole owners and attachers already
operate in states where an FCC based
formula is in
place New Hampshire currently is truly
unique and an outlier
relative to calculating pole attachment
rates again in the event of a
dispute we have submitted written
testimony or I have testimony that I
will submit and there is more
information in that uh regarding the
practice in other
states so the advantages of a formula
based on based on the FCC formula are
numerous it's well known and understood
to parties it has been found to be
non-discriminatory and fully
compensatory to poll owners and fair to
attachers it has been fully litigated
under federal
law this type of certainty would
actually reduce the likelihood of
litigation which is expensive and is
also a cost that is passed on to rate
payers my understanding to give you an
example is that in Massachusetts where
an FCC based formula is in place there
has not been a dispute on rates since
the
1990s importantly this bill also calls
upon the agency to develop an
accelerated dispute resolution
process in December of 2023 in
recognizing that lengthy and expensive
disputes were delaying investment in in
Broadband deployment the FCC adopted an
accelerated dispute resolution process
for the 30 states that are not certified
and who defer poll regulation to the FCC
for New Hampshire which is
certified uh to the FCC that it will
regulate
disputes an accelerated dispute
resolution process should be
Paramount quick resolution of disputes
in the event of a dispute
provides more predictability certainty
and frankly it discourages unnecessary
disputes again it's important to note
that most New Hampshire poll operators
and attachers operate in states where
these processes are already
law such an expedited process is key
when one considers that in many cases
polls are owned by the competitors to
the entities which are seeking to attach
to them utility polls are among the last
remaining Monopoly Assets in an
increasingly deregulated industry there
is no economically viable alternative to
attaching to utility poles for Wired
networks and there should be no
anti-competitive incentive to create
delay in
deployment the avoidance of disputes
expeditious expeditious resolution of
disputes relative to pull attachment
rates is is significant in that again
money and time is not spent on
litigation when rapid deployment is
key lastly Senate Bill 595 clarifies
that the agency has the authority to
implement the statute and require pole
owners to maintain the necessary records
to justify their poll attachment rates
and make that information available to
the attachers to verify the accuracy of
rates transparency in record keep in and
in the process is of utmost importance
so in
conclusion uh just to summarize we
believe that this clarifies the law it
absolutely aligns New Hampshire with
other states it creates predictability
in calculating pole attachment rates
creates processes for dispute avoidance
and expeditious
resolution it improves
transparency and truly it helps a line
Resources with priorities around
deployment of infrastructure so we ask
that you recommend Senate Bill 595 ought
to pass as amended by the Senate and I'd
like to turn to Susan to see if she has
comments to add and we're happy to take
your questions thank
you good morning um I don't have
anything in particular to add to what
Mora has stated but I would be happy to
take any questions that the committee
may have
so I have a question for you Miss Weston
mentioned that an accelerated dispute
resolution process is
needed I read through the text of this
bill and I don't see any mention of that
is it somewhere in here that I just
don't see or can you explain that to me
that's right I think that in um what
would become the new section
um see
I think it's 10
A6 um that that would give the
department of energy
um the commission I'm sorry the
commission need would need to conduct a
formal root rule making to incorporate
the formula that the department of
energy develops along with rules for
Accelerated dispute resolution that's on
the the um line 24 correct yes
okay thank you further questions for
Miss geyser representative
muns thank you Mr chair and um thank you
for coming in and meeting with us this
morning um as an organization that um uh
does cover um all of New England uh I'm
I'm wondering if you can uh answer the
question I had asked earlier about
um what the impact or how how rates in
New Hampshire currently compare to Maine
Vermont Massachusetts Connecticut and
you know what would the what would the
impact of this be on those
rates yes I can give you one data point
um in in New Hampshire Consolidated
Communications and this was back in as
of 2022 this is the data I have
Consolidated in New Hampshire charges
for a solely owned poll poll that it
owns by itself um it charges each
attacher or I'll say it charges um some
necta members as attachers
$167 per year per attachment so for
every attachment on every single poll
that Consolidated owned in
2022 each of those attachments was
assessed the charge of
$167 on a solely owned pole in Maine the
comparable figure or charge was
$356 so and on a jointly owned poll on a
poll that Consolidated owned with
another entity like eversource for
example um Consolidated charged
$684 in New Hampshire per attachment per
poll annually and in Maine uh
consolidated charge
a178 thank you okay I additional
questions representative licki has one
chairman thank you for taking my
question um are there businesses in New
Hampshire that have been um unable to
operate either temporarily or in the
longer term because they were not able
to attach to polls or was this strictly
a financial uh
issue thank you for the question I I'll
I'll phrase it this way to the extent
that that a pole attacher is trying to
gain access to polls to serve new
customers and is unable to
negotiate a rate with the pole owner
then deployment of the attachers assets
will be delayed we think this bill will
eliminate that delay in Broadband
deployment by allowing a formulaic
approach to the issue of what rates
should be charged uh to that attacher
and that can expedite deployment
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair um and this question
may have been asked I was late to the
hearing uh so if it it has been I
apologize um how many poll disputes um
occur on a yearly
basis I'm only aware in the last say 12
years at the Pu I'm aware of two cases
that actually went to
adjudication I'm not familiar with the
number of disputes that occur that are
um resolved informally I'm just aware of
two cases that were actually adjudicated
at the PC there may have been more
representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in this morning to to talk to us
uh I was just talking to my wife this
morning and she mentioned that we have
two internet providers in our town and
if I understand you correctly this bill
would increase the number of Internet
providers in rural areas would that be
correct to to to draw that
conclusion I I I don't see that this
bill actually goes to that issue but I
think to the extent that the bill
provides certainty and an objectively
reasonable standard for setting pole
attachment rates I think it will be
perhaps more efficient and expeditious
for a potential attacher to reach
agreement with the pole owner so that
the attachers broad facilities could be
deployed more expeditiously than
currently representative followup go
ahead so so this bill
would possibly benefit um operators are
already in the state it would not bring
in are you saying you to your knowledge
there are no waiting you know there's
not a backlog of people waiting to get
into the state to do business on those
polls I I don't I don't have the answer
to that that
question representative Harrington has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question we had a lot of
discussion with the previous uh speakers
on um what the effect with this would be
so it appears if I'm correct me if I'm
wrong on this but it appears that there
would be really no negotiation on either
the attacher or the pole owner's part
they would simply go to the formula and
figure out okay I'm going to get charged
I can charge you x amount that's what
I'm going to charge you or or on the
attachers point of view saying you can
only charge me x amount that's what I'm
going to pay you and what would be any
why would anyone negotiate a different
rate if it was already know that the
fallback was based on statute I mean
that's the one it's going to be
effectively become the rate isn't it so
I'll start and then maybe Susan can back
clean up to help answer the
question uh the FCC formula
has been or I should say 30 or so States
uh seed authority to the
FCC and the FCC formula it is well known
it has been adjudicated it is supported
by a body of law that is comp U
compensatory and just um for for both
parties and my sense is poll attachment
negotiations occur regularly there are
voluntary agreements
knowing that this body of law
exists I don't see that it that this
bill changes the voluntary negotiations
between the parties
whatsoever uh these factors are well
known what we're talking about is what
happens in the event of a dispute and
the six factor analysis under our
regulations are vague and amorphous
and
create I think challenges and may lead
to more disputes rather than fewer
disputes that's my general sense Susan
do you I'll just add one quick thing um
representative Harrington the poll
attachers and the pole owners negotiate
these voluntary agreements rates are
just one element of those agreements
there are other terms and conditions for
Access that are contained in those
agreements so I don't think it's necess
neily a given that a rate that is
produced by this for formula is
automatically going to be uh inserted
into the contract there may be some give
and take in that negotiation process
whereby the poll attacher is willing to
pay a higher rate for more favorable
terms and conditions that are not
Financial I thank you representative
muns has the last question for these two
thank you Mr chair yeah I just want to
follow up on that um um Exchange with
representative Harrington so so if I if
I heard what you said
correctly 595 would not impose a
specific rate that it would only be a
rate that would go into effect if the
parties couldn't negotiate so they would
still be
negotiating that's
correct okay thank you I would just like
to add one quick thing to that and is my
understanding that this is not one size
fits-all when you look at the formula it
really comes down to inputs and one set
of inputs for one pole owner could look
very different than the inputs for
another pole owner so this is not one
size fits-all but I would add any
formula that is adopted and if it's
based on the FCC formulas must be fully
compensatory to the pole owner regarding
the cost associated with that attachment
so I think representative Harrington may
have asked this question earlier about
the UTI's ability or the poll owner's
ability to recover its cost the FCC and
the courts have held that the fcc's
formulas are fully compensatory and
they're just and reasonable and that's
what rate making is all about is to
produce a just and reasonable
rate okay you've helped us a lot to
understand the issues here so I want to
thank you both for coming to talk to us
this morning thank you next we'll hear
from one of the largest pole owners in
the state ever Source Michael Lata will
give us his P perspective on this
legislation good morning and
welcome good
morning Michael Lata representing
eversource and as uh the chair pointed
out we uh own either in whole or in part
uh
48 uh I'm sorry 480,000
utility polls uh throughout our service
territory in New Hampshire and we are uh
in support of the legislation before you
today um the reason that we support is
because we do believe uh that there is
value in the department of energy
setting a uniform formula rate uh that
would be used uh in the case of disputes
by the Public Utilities Commission we
think that that will provide a level of
consistency and transparency that would
benefit both poll owners as well as
attachers and ultimately uh customers of
both uh telecommunication services and
uh our our customers our electric rate
payer
customers um as uh I think was mentioned
by representative partial uh in 2013 the
Public Utilities Commission uh did in
fact approve a settlement uh between
eversource and several
telecommunications Pro uh providers uh
which set set the formula rate that
eversource uses today so our rate has
actually been set excuse me our formula
has actually been set by pu order which
I think is is a little bit unusual
compared to the other electric
distribution
utilities um and so that is a a bit of a
blended rate uh between the FCC
telecommunications and FCC cable rates
uh and that is the formula that we we
apply today um and with that I'll just
say that I appreciate the bill sponsor
and other stakeholders willingness to
work with us uh in the Senate to address
concerns uh that we had raised
originally with the bill uh and we are
in support of the legislation before you
today okay thank you representative muts
has a question thank you Mr chair thank
you Mr LCA for being here uh we heard
just in previous testimony that um that
uh in Maine at least um the the rates
for uh pole the pole attachment rates
are lower than they currently are in New
Hampshire so assuming that that is the
case in that that would happen in New
Hampshire as well
um you would suffer a pretty significant
Revenue loss on your 4 180,000 polls how
would you make that up yeah I think
there's an assumption in in the question
and I think there's been assumptions
made um during the hearing today that um
the doe is going to make a finding of a
a substantially different formula than
we have in place today or something
lower uh than we have today as uh
attorney guer had said um you know the
FCC formula is designed to um uh make
pole owners whole uh but also there are
other factors uh unique to New Hampshire
potentially that the department of
energy and the Public Utilities
Commission would take into account when
either setting the rate or or uh
mediating a dispute so um you know it
really depends on the rate that the
department of energy would set and the
uh resolution of a dispute uh that the
Public Utilities Commission uh would
mediate between pole owners and pole
attachers on on whether there would be
uh a change in in Revenue followup
follow up
um the the rate that was negotiated or
adjudicate ated by the the Pu what what
is that rate I was worried you were
going to ask me that but I did come
prepared um so it is
0.44 times the space Factor times the
net cost of the bare pole squared times
the carrying charge rate squared and the
space Factor formula which I can go into
if you'd like uh is is also in uh um in
the order and that's basically the
usable space of the pole uh the pole
height the number of
attachers uh and the usable
space did you need to follow up on that
uh so say it's it's a fairly technical
formula that reminds me of the joke
about the accountant when you know when
someone asked him if they could explain
something and the accountant gave a very
precise answer and person said well you
must be an accountant because it you
know doesn't help me at all all I can
promise you I'm not an accountant okay
thank you all right further questions
for Mr Lata representative
Kaplan uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr lato I'm going to try my luck
with you uh and ask my the same question
do you in your opinion do do you think
this bill would increase the number of
businesses operating in the state in
terms of uh internet providers and and
cable providers like that I I I would
say um potentially you
know in the puc order back in
2013 um the Commission in its findings
noted that uh by setting the formula
rate that they did uh their Hope was
that it would increase the amount of
telecommunications infrastructure in the
state while balancing obviously the the
interest of of customers and and
shareholders so having a standardized
formula does that make the state more
attractive to a broadband provider I
mean you'd have to ask them but um you
know I think that was part of the uh the
commission's analysis when approving our
formula
rate representative Kennedy has a
question yeah the the last speaker said
that the bill would increase the
standing of the FCC rules so I'm a
little confused are we ignoring those
rules now so it I I will
so I will say no um
there in the case of eversource
settlement formula which was adopted in
2013 um they are quite consistent with
different components of FCC formula
rates so there's a telecommunication
rate and there's a uh cable rate please
don't ask me why they're differentiated
uh perhaps Miss Gyer attorney guer could
uh could explain that um but but it is
uh that does form the basis and I would
also note there has been mention of sort
of the six Factor test that the
commission uh is required to use when uh
adjudicate adjudicating disputes and the
FCC formula rate is is one of those
factors in
that representative PL has a
question thank you chair thank you Mr
Lata uh I'm still hung up on the need of
this um going just to mention um Miss
lon's comment she said there was a
legislation um my notes are not as good
as representative corman's
F that was put in in 2007 I don't expect
you to noce I'm leading up to the
question okay but hasn't been used to
2023 then there was another
disputes if I heard right goes back to
1990 I'll check what represent Corbin of
all my ears
but everu being a major player my
question is can you share some of the
disputes you had that needed to go to
the Pu in the last few years thank you
yeah I'll there has been made reference
to a recent dispute that was not a
dispute that involved ever source is
what what I will say um you know we did
have the settlement that I referenced
that was uh a complaint that was filed
back uh by
telecommunications providers back in
2012 and was uh again the end result of
that is we were able to come to a
settlement file that settlement uh
agreement with the Pu that was approved
and that has been um the formula that
that we have used I I'll you know I
don't want to sort of overstep I'll
defer to others in the telecommunication
space who might speak to the specifics
of of the most recent dispute and that I
think uh moved things along and the uh
the legislation that you uh that you
referenced I think was the um that six
part uh that six Factor test that the
commission is required to use when uh
determining whether a uh a formula rate
is is fair and in the public
interest
followup real quick uh thank you you did
answer my question question thank you
okay we need to move on here we've got
one more speaker representative Thomas
may you have a quick question yes I do
um thank you for being here uh was ever
Source unhappy with the pole dispute
process prior to the case that initiated
this
bill uh I I think the answer to that is
no okay let's move on and give the last
word to and I'm going to apologize for
getting this name wrong Meg
gonier and I'm not sure who Meg
represents but she'll tell us hi good
morning what is your last name Meg
glander glander g l gler
d all right thank you y good morning
chairman and members of the committee my
name is Meg glander and I represent
crown castle for the record we are the
nation's largest provider of shared
telecommunications infrastructure uh our
work is crucial cral in providing
connectivity to Anchor institutions
across New England including to schools
state and local governments hospitals
Public Safety businesses and major
Wireless carriers and cable companies in
New Hampshire alone we represent over
100 government school and Public Safety
customers and have 500 miles of Route
fiber facilitating vital Communications
across the state on which every sector
individual and Community relies as a
neutral host provider collaborating
across various sectors here in the State
Crown Castle is uniquely positioned to
discuss today's topic an essential
component of infrastructure that's often
overlooked until it becomes a bottleneck
in our shared goal of closing the
digital divide and ensuring fast
reliable connectivity utility
polls these polls are vital as they
provide a prevalent and widely available
foundation on which to deploy the wire
line and wireless facilities necessary
to deliver the connectivity that granted
State residents require and deserve
without timely access to well-maintained
utility polls at reasonable and
transparent rates terms and conditions
providing this connectivity becomes a
serious
challenge which is why we support Senate
Bill 595 as amended this legislation
represents a crucial step towards
resolving significant inefficiencies in
New Hampshire's poll attachment system
currently aiming to replace the current
2007 vague multiactor rate test with a
clear formula based rate system to
streamline processes increasing
transparency and reducing unnecessary
delays this formula will leverage
historical cost data ensuring rates are
fair transparent and consistent with
practices in neighboring states like
Maine and Vermont as well as in line
with the poll attachment formula set by
the Federal Communications Commission
this law of course would be proactive to
new disputes I'd like to highlight we
were not a party to that dispute
everybody keeps talking about with the
Public Utility Commission um in addition
an accelerated dispute resolution
process which is in line with what the
FCC recently adopted given all of the
funding for Broadband federally um would
be something we strongly support
currently resolving disputes can take up
to 180 days in the state in the digital
age where connectivity is increasingly
synonymous with opportunity safety and
access to vital Services these delays
are
unacceptable this bill will sign if ific
L reduced timelines ensuring um
resolutions and facilitating faster
Broadband deployment which becomes
increasingly important as we look at the
historic moment we're
in with $318 million from the federal
government allocated to New Hampshire
for Broadband expansion through arpa and
the be programs timely and fair access
to utility polls has become even more
critical while these polls might seem
mundane they're the backbone of our
efforts to connect every corner of the
state in a cost effective way delays in
accessing polls can also jeopardize not
only the timely use of federal funds but
also our broader goals of connectivity
and economic growth in Practical terms
imagine a scenario where a deployment is
stalled because the poll owner and the
Broadband provider cannot agree on poll
attachment rates or dispute stragon for
months if a poll owner is Slow Rolling
negotiating a poll attachment agreement
or granting access that's where
accelerated dispute resolution can
really save projects otherwise these
delays could mean not only missing out
on federal dead deadlines but also
delaying crucial connectivity for
schools that need internet for learning
for hospitals that rely on data for
patient care and for businesses that
need Broadband to complete compete in
the global
Marketplace in addition as a company
that attaches Wireless facilities to
polls we want to highlight that the vast
majority of 911 calls are made via a
wireless device on un served and un uh
unserved and underserved areas POS a
significant risk in situations where
timely arrival by First Responders could
quite literally mean the difference
between life and death the last thing we
need in upgrading this kind of
infrastructure are unnecessary delays
caused by unpredictable pole attachment
disputes in conclusion we urge the
committee to support Senate Bill 595
ensuring that New Hampshire doesn't miss
out on an unprecedented opportunity to
enhance its Communications
infrastructure and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you do you have written
testimony to submit by any chance I
could send it to you I don't have it on
me though okay thank you I appreciate
that questions representative Harrington
has one thank you chairman and thank you
for taking my question um we've been
talking generally about attachments here
but uh that can involve more than just
putting up a new wire on a telephone
poll uh what I'm referring to do you
think this bill addresses the issue of
all right there's a telephone pole it's
got an electric wire on it it's got uh
two communication wires on it and now
two more companies want to put things on
there and it requires movement of the
existing ones probably not the electric
one because that's going to always be on
top but the other two so does this bill
cover the cost associated with I've
already paid you my wire's up there now
you want me to move it so you can put
another wire up there yeah great
question I was talking to my team before
about this so when we put a node we do
an engineering analysis for a kind of
node we would attach to a poll so what
would happen in that scenario is we'd
still if if it was on us on our
attachment we would still have to bear
the cost of replacing the pole through
our normal negotiation process so that's
irrespective kind of of this what we're
talking about here what what what I'm
follow up go ahead yeah what what I'm
referring to here is that the poll's
there it's existing now a new company
comes in and says I want to attach to
the poll and they make an agreement with
the the owner of the pole does that
include the cost of another company
that's already attached to the pole
having to move their wire because they
physically needs to be spaced out more
because you you're adding one or two
more wires to the pole so is this bill
going to cover that addition because
someone's going to have to pay for that
if company a is has to move their wire
because Company B wants to attach
company a wants to get paid for doing it
does this bill address that issue yeah
we're currently not seeing problems with
that in this state the One Touch make
ready process that's kind of separate
from this um discussion but we would
have the normal negotiation process when
we're going back and forth with the pole
owner um and this would just come into
play to have a predictable process so
it's like you're not driving your car
without a GPS you know um so you know
what the the formula is when you talk to
the company beforehand to prevent
disputes representative mons thank you
Mr chair and thank you for uh coming in
um you you you spoke quite a bit about
um the importance of an accelerated
dispute resolution mechanism and and and
some other speakers spoke about that as
well do you feel that the bill includes
enough
Direction um on that uh I mean right now
it's mentioned you know in one place um
as a you know General a accelerated
dispute resolution mechanism do you
think that the legislature needs to be a
little bit more specific in terms of
what that should
include I think is currently written
with the um process that will be under
taken after this bill is hopefully
passed with the Department of energy
that all stakeholders will get to weigh
in and really come up with what's best
for the stakeholders of New Hampshire
whether it's the poll owners um or the
Broadband providers so I think is
currently written yes it's it's
enough followup followup um but what if
the if the you know the
the the the the department comes back
and says you know yeah we'll resolve
issues within 180 days I mean that
doesn't sound expedited does it no and I
don't think that's the intent uh here
it's to resolve disputes within 30 60 90
days representative
Kennedy thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question um representative
Harrington was asking if the bill would
address a very specific issue but you
know when I read this there's nothing
specific in this bill it says that a
formula shall be developed so how could
you even answer a question like
that well this bill again will take all
stakeholders and the department of
energy um to be able to come up with a
um rate based on historical cost data um
so yeah I mean I understand what you're
saying but this will instead of a vague
six-part multiactor test where you
really can't predict things would put
a formula based approach it's clear and
transparent okay seeing no further
questions I want to thank you for being
here and uh testifying to us this
morning and that will conclude our
public hearing on Senate Bill 595 FN and
since we
are uh significantly behind schedule
here I'm going to go directly into
Senate Bill
603 and ask Grant bossy from uh Senator
Bradley's office to introduce this
legislation to us thank
you good morning Mr
bossy good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee thank you very much my
name is Grant bossy Deputy Chief of
Staff for the New Hampshire Senate and
I'm here to introduce Senate Bill 603 on
behalf of Senator Jeb Bradley the Bill's
Prime sponsor what is unique
New Hampshire we lost the old man in the
mountains nearly 21 years ago our first
in the nation primary is under attack
even Daniel Webster moved to
Massachusetts to run for the Senate but
we still have three numbers that are
unique to the Granite State
63 in use since 1947 for granite Staters
603 is more than an area code it's an
identity we have songs and bumper
stickers and political slogans and craft
beers and t-shirts 603 is New Hampshire
and New Hampshire is 603 the growth of
mobile devices has put a strain on the
603 area code which of course can never
accommodate more than 10 million unique
phone numbers at a time if we want to
Forstall the need for a second area code
in New Hampshire perhaps as soon as
2027 we need to find a way to reassign
dormant and unused numbers to new phone
lines Governor sonunu last year signed
an executive order to extend the life of
the 603 area code but changes in statute
are also needed Senate Bill 603 would
empower the New Hampshire Department of
energy and the Public Utilities
Commission to adopt conservation
measures to the greatest extent Allowed
by federal law such as reclaiming
defunct and abandoned numbers it would
require service providers of voice over
internet protocols or VoIP to register
with the Department of energy when
requesting numbering Services I would
defer technical questions to the
Department of energy but if you have
questions for Senator Bradley I'll make
sure to get you an answer thank you for
your consideration and hopefully support
of Senate Bill
603 okay thank you representative ner
does have a question for you thank you
it's good to see you grant so I'm a
little bit confused because um people
get a new cell phone and they often have
somebody else's number an old number so
isn't that already done I think the
department can already speak to why
numbers might be dormant and not
available for reissue and that makes one
less number that we have in the 603 area
code before for instance Massachusetts
several years ago had to add
508 okay no followup required
representative Kaplan would like to ask
a question thank you Mr chair and thanks
for coming in I have a question about
the utility of this bill in terms of the
amount of time that it saves us at some
point there will be a need for another
area go do you have an idea of what the
time frame would be for that if this
bill were to pass I don't I think if New
Hampshire's population keeps rising and
we keep using phones uh we're not you
know replaced with some sort of Wi-Fi
implant in our heads uh we're probably
going to need a second area code at some
point this would move that date down the
line um well right now I think there
without the executive order last year
without this bill um the department
estimated we'd run out of numbers in
2027 that's just three years away so
this would push it down the line I'm not
sure how much hopefully the department
can tell you how much how much more life
in the area code we can get out of
this okay seeing no further questions I
want to thank you and Senator Bradley
for submitting this uh legislation and
we'll next hear from Chris Rand from the
Granite State Communications we heard
from Chris earlier and like to get his
perspective on this legislation as well
welcome
back thank you Mr chairman I I'm again
representing New Hampshire telephone
Association um few very brief com
comments for the committee this
morning um the rural carriers in the New
Hampshire telephone Association have not
been the numbering resource problem in
the past because we just don't hold that
many numbers um the challenges inherent
in moving for our members in moving to
thousands block
pooling um would be uh High and the
reward would be fairly low again because
we hold very few blocks of numbers it's
not even clear that all the New
Hampshire telephone Association members
have the technology to implement
thousands blog pooling um we are in
favor of the amendment which simply
would
clarify uh that um that the thousands
block pooling is uh a not a mandatory
process it's a voluntary
process and that concludes my
comments thank you could you clarify
what amendment you're referring to are
you refer referring to the amended
version of the bill as it came over from
the
Senate um I believe so yes it it it
inserts the words that all service
providers that have chosen to
participate in thousands block
pooling do you know do you have a line
number where that language might appear
um I have it it shows in section two I
don't have the full text of it here
um so it would
be it would be around SE in in the
version I have around line
19 so it currently says starting on line
18 ensuring that all service providers
are in compliance with the fcc's
regulations on thousand thousands block
number
pooling and ordering rate Center
consolidation that it determines
necessary after review and
investigation so you're and and the
amendment re requested in that section
was that all service providers that have
chosen to participate in thousands block
pooling are in compliance oh okay all
right I'll have to double check my email
to see U what we've received on that but
okay I didn't recall that um
what exactly the language you wanted was
it wasn't clear on whether it was
already in the amended version from the
senate or whether it was something you
were asking us to do but I understand
now so thank you so representative muns
has a question thank you Mr chair I got
two just technical questions um what is
what is Thousands block number pooling
and what is a rate what our rate Center
consolidations so thousands block
pooling is is
are numbers are handed out on an NPA NXX
basis where there are 10,000 numbers in
that block and then thousands block
pooling is breaking that group of 10,000
numbers into 10 1,000 block pools of
numbers and then those are distributed
amongst the different carriers in an
area such as conquered Manchester ashaa
more urban areas where there is
competition so they're allocated on that
basis rather than these large
blocks and then what is a a rate Center
consolidation so that would be where
there are um there are multiple blocks
spread over a a rate
Center and they're not used as
efficiently as could be and the the that
process of thousand block pooling is
implemented to reduce the numbers that
are allocated to a specific carrier in
that rate Center and the remaining
thousands blocks are allocated amongst
the competitors that may be operating in
that
area so the basic problem here is that
there are numbers that are no longer
being used that need to be recaptured so
that they can be used in the future
correct yes
yep in areas sorry go ahead pardon me
for interrupting do you know of any
other states that have done this kind of
phone number conservation
successfully I believe it's in place all
over the country yes our our position
and coming here today was simply to
clarify that we don't have the nhta
members operate in very rural areas and
we don't have the ability to implement
some of these steps so we just want to
clarify that this that that is a a
voluntary not a mandatory process as
written uh we could Envision a time down
the road where a a mandatory
implementation of this may result in the
entire block of numbers from a rural
carrier being taken back so it's simply
uh cleaning up the language okay great
thank you further questions
representative lii has one uh thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question in a block are the numbers
consecutive or can they the block be a
bunch of recycled
numbers in a block of a
thousand um they are I believe that
they're consecutive I'm not as familiar
with that because we don't participate
in it um but they're definitely they're
sequential yes yep and I believe each
carrier is given a thousand numbers at a
time followup followup uh so there's no
form of what in computers we called
garbage collection where um uh the
computer would find unused files and in
this case find unused phone numbers
phone number that hasn't been assigned
and um recycle
them that's a very good question and I'm
not because we haven't been involved in
thousands of block pooling we've asked
the same question because there is
porting
where a customer of a landline company
May Port their number to a wireless
company and we've always asked that
question is when somebody takes that and
Associates it with their wireless
service and then disconnects that
service how does that number make its
way back to the original carrier and
we're we're just not familiar enough
it's not as widespread as an issue for
us okay thanks for giving us your
perspective now let's hear from Karen
Susi who's going to represent the
CTI and I don't remember what that
stands for but I'm sure she'll tell
us oh goodness good morning Mr chair
members of the committee my name is
Karen Susi I work at shanin Capital
group and I'm here representing CTI
we'll just call it the wireless
Association so your T-Mobile's AT&T
Verizon US Cellular sorry I spoke away
from the microphone um and and we we are
in opposition to the bill
um we definitely appreciate uh the
meaning of the 603 area code the brand
the identity that it brings to residents
of the State of New Hampshire I think
what we need to consider though is how
it's being done and it's being done
through a fee or a new tax to the
carriers in order to implement to bring
it fruition and I think that's something
that we definitely need to consider
certainly especially when there's
already $30 million each year brought in
from the commun communication Services
tax that's put into the general fund so
we certainly don't have a clear number
of what the uh fee or tax would be that
causes us angst um we're not sure if
it's a one-time assessment we're not
sure if it's something that will
continue on can they keep coming coming
at us when there are other issues that
they need to investigate or
establish so again we do understand
certainly I'm a granite stator been here
my whole life my grandparents my great
parents grandparents have been here I
understand um but again we need to think
about how we're doing this and possibly
I would suggest find this alternative
funding source and use
it okay questions for Miss Susi uh
representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman and thank you thank you for
taking my question I just want to make
sure I understand your point here so are
you saying that the carriers will have
to spend money actually implementing uh
this procedure and therefore that would
get passed on to their customers so it's
my understanding that the department is
suggesting that there be this fact or
excuse me fee or tax to essentially hire
a consultant to investigate how to
implement this we haven't been given a
specific number it could vary um we're
not sure if it's going to be Equitable
or not to all carriers um and of course
I'm certainly sure there is the
possibility that that could be a pass
through to
customers so
your assessment here is
that the state is already collecting $30
million worth of communication tax from
your
members which gets passed along to rate
payers and then this is another cost
that would get passed along to rate
payers correct because the fiscal note
says that such costs would be paid
through a special utility assessment on
all providers of telecommunication
services so you're seeing this as just
an increase in taxes that are going to
be paid by rate payers correct yes
that's correct thank you representative
N I think you've just already answered
my question so thank you oh okay thank
you representative
Harrington thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question Let's uh
let's go way back in time I remember
this issue came up when I was on the
commission and uh I believe it was like
15 years ago or something when it was
you know saved the 603 was the calling
card for this movement and I don't even
remember what we did but I I think back
then you had to get blocks of 10,000 was
the minimum amount of numbers you can
buy and that was changed so at least for
if I'm correct in my memory about 15
years we've been able to keep all
telephone numbers in New Hampshire is
603 what is what what isn't working now
that we can continue to do that that we
need a new program and a new
assessment you know I I did look briefly
back at that I think there's an effort
in 2000 and possibly 2010 or 11 uh to do
something to conserve the area code uh
the only thing I could figure out was
that they did not use an assessment or a
tax or fee to do so um you have more
experience with that than I do and
fortunately all right thank you I don't
remember a tax of fee being associated
with either but I could be wrong thank
you additional questions for Miss Susi
representative
bernardy thank you Mr chair uh um so
looking at the looking at the fiscal
note uh it talks about $100,000 to
$300,000 cost in the fiscal year 25 26
period so it looks like a one-time cost
um but
uh if this approach has been used in
multiple other states
already why cannot we just pick up
what's been learned there and not have
to pay this it doesn't make any sense do
you understand why we need this this
costing I I do not understand why we
need this I think that's a question for
the Department again if there's a cost
that needs to be associated with doing
this I would strongly urge people to
look to that communication Services tax
which is already being taken in would
wouldn't require the dup excuse me the
duplicative efforts of the department to
seek out additional funding thank
you additional questions for Miss sus
seeing none and hers being the last pink
card I have on this uh to testify on
this bill I would like to ask the
department if they would be willing to
come up and ask answer a couple of
questions for us thank you for uh
volunteering to do that I appreciate it
yes and apologies I did fill out a pink
card it perhaps got lost along the way
so my apologies for that but we're happy
to to be here answer your lost somewhere
and provide
information it
was same the same bill was referenced
both times that's why we
had two testimonies for 595 and none for
this oh okay so I guess you forgot you
wrote the wrong bill number on the early
morning error on my part my apologies
you're
forgiven well good morning um we're
happy to be here and talk about Senate
Bill 603 um I think you all all heard
about how 603 is an iconic New Hampshire
symbol AS New Hampshire residents were
all familiar with the branding and the
importance of our 603 area code on our
local economy um it is we are one of a
handful of single area code states
remaining in the country um our
neighbors in Maine are also a single
area code State and while we've been
very successful with past efforts that
you heard representative Harrington talk
about excuse me in 2000 when we
implemented thousand block pooling and
in
2011 um we find ourselves being notified
by Nampa which is the North American
numbering plan administrator who
oversees the
administration and the numbering
resources for the country that our area
code will exhaust in the the second
quarter of
2027 looking to our neighbors in Maine
they were in a similar position in
2021 um they had a projection of areic
cod exhaust in uh
2024 and they undertook a number of
steps that we've looked at we've
Incorporated many of those same steps um
and they were able to push their area
code exhaust out 10 years to 2034
whether we'd have the same success or
not um we don't know our our
demographics and economic makeup are a
little bit different but we're very
optimistic that we can push out with um
efforts the life of the 603 area code
for some time to come um perhaps enough
time for the federal government to
determine how to number across the whole
country as we these numbers it's a
finite resource they'll dwindle and a
new plan a new numbering plan for the
whole country will come into place some
point down the
road
20ish years 25 years is the projection
so we'd like to keep our single area
code for as long as we can and uh be a
part of um the the robust New Hampshire
economy that comes from that there are
some questions about thousand block
pooling and what rate Center
consolidation was that Mr Rand addressed
um I I just wanted to be clear
that the North American numbering plan
administrator or Nampa holds the numbers
for all states and assigns blocks of
numbers that's the Thousand block or a
code which is a
10,000 pool of numbers um out to
Providers since the early 2000s um with
the exception of some of the small rural
carriers like Granite State Telecom um
Bretton Woods Dunbarton Telecom all
providers in New Hampshire have obtained
their numbers in blocks of 1,000 um
prior to that they were getting their
numbers in blocks of 10,000 and many of
them still hold those 10,000 number
blocks and there are likely numbers in
there that are not being used that could
be um made available
for other residents to use other
businesses to use in the state of New
Hampshire and help increase the
available um available numbers what this
bill does
is in essence it it it it closes a
loophole so to speak so the department
today has the obligation to preserve
numbering resources in the 603 area code
and we have the authority
to um assess ass utilities those that we
regulate for the cost of any Consultants
that we hire in this instance the
utilities those that we regulate the
incumbent local exchange carriers the
landline
providers um they're not the only ones
using numbers and so it seems Equitable
that all use all providers that use
telephone numbers in New Hampshire
should contribute to um the cost of this
consultant
that the department would hire for this
investigation um we've issued an RFP we
have some bid responses in I'm pleased
to say that those responses are in the
range of the fiscal note so for um a
three-year uh a contract the cost would
be relatively minimal spread across all
the service providers that use numbers
into the Hampshire um the Department's
proposal um at this point is to use uh
publicly available reports that identify
how many blocks those are the Thousand
number blocks how many numbering
resources a provider has and allocate
the cost of the consultant's contract
based on that so it' be a very minimal
charge over three years to any of these
providers it is a
one-time Project Specific assessment
it's not a tax it's not a ongoing fee um
it's a special assessment for the cost
of this
project yes I'm trying to think if I
answered all the questions that came up
to this point but please go ahead I
didn't realize you were finished I'm
sorry representative Bernardi has a
question thank you Mr chair so I guess
uh this is the same question I asked
Miss Susie uh you know if Maine has
already done this and other states have
already done this why can't we learn
from them without so high a consultant
cost sure well we'll certainly be
looking to what um other states have
done or considering doing um with the
reorganization of the Public Utilities
Commission and the creation of the
Department of energy in 2021 there was
um
the elimination of the the group that
worked on telecommunications issues and
so this consultant would replace that
industry knowledge and provide a much
needed resource to us as we move through
these
processes so on line 26 of the bill it
says that the department May specially
assess these providers for the costs of
Investigations and other other Pursuit
other proceedings pursuant to
Etc how would the department feel if we
change that language to require the
department to
obtain uh funds from the fiscal
committee to cover those
costs in other words use general fund re
revenues rather than assessments to
telephone
providers I certainly think that's a
policy decision for you all to make and
whichever path you believe is more
appropriate we're happy to
follow and what do you think of the
suggestion that was made
earlier that this pooling of thousand
block numbers be made voluntary rather
than mandatory yes thank you I knew
there was a point that I had missed and
that was Mr rand's comment about um the
amendment that uh that he was
referencing Ing we did see some language
from the New Hampshire telephone
Association that would have added in
that
um for for service providers that have
chosen to participate in Thousand block
pooling that in New Hampshire is only
the rural teleone companies all the
other companies do participate in
Thousand block pooling so we're
absolutely fine with that as Mr Rand
pointed out the service area their their
survey um aren't aren't
the big Urban centers where there's huge
demand for a lot of numbers um they have
their blocks of numbers their their
10,000 code to serve their customers and
businesses within their
communities okay let's go first with
representative
Harrington um yeah just so I get clear
what you're saying um at right now the
the tax is being paid only by the uh
incumbent landline operators and not
like cell phones and so
forth so there is no tax okay right so
we have our uh utility General
assessment yeah under RSA
363a which uh tele regulated telephone
companies uh pay into um based on 33% of
their revenues other utilities pay based
on 100% of their revenues but because
telephone companies are only lightly
regulated their their assessment is a
little bit lower but this there is no
such assessment okay on um uh certain vo
providers um or on uh cellular providers
right so they're not paying anything for
our our general uh work on Telephone
numbering which is constant as as you
may remember right um
this would be like a consultant fee that
would be specially assessed that's under
a different section of the statute
whenever we uh have a proceeding and we
need to hire some sort of expertise or
even a stenographer those costs are uh
specially assessed to the utilities
involved right um this would extend that
special assessment to cell phone
providers just for this contract right
the the the landline telephone company
compies are already paying right um this
would just add them and sort of close
the loop so that the the payment
mechanism is fair and it's it really is
quite minimal uh
followup yes um okay just in general I
mean we've been fighting this battle now
for over 20 years um I make a lot of
phone calls to people that live in New
Hampshire that don't have a 603 area
code my daughter lives in Massachusetts
she has a 603 area code maybe it's just
time we said because you have to punch
in 603 now it's not like it was a couple
of years ago uh so it maybe it's just
time we say enough give it up and uh you
know stop chasing the the goal that
we're going to lose on eventually
because eventually we're going to run
out of numbers and just say you know we
we kept it 603 as long as we could time
to say uh you know State's too big to
handle one area code
comments the governor wouldn't be happy
with that uh
idea you don't have to uh answer that
question since it's a policy issue
representative
Kaplan yeah I mean actually this is a
probably the same question I'm just
going to word it slightly differently I
understand the iconic value of having a
603 area code and the cultural
significance and you know what it means
to people but you mentioned an economic
benefit of having the 603 area code or
maybe a single area code can you
elucidate what that economic benefit
might be
so I think as you all most likely have
seen there's a number of businesses that
market themselves with 603 in the name
of their business that there's
merchandise there's mugs there's
t-shirts there's sweatshirts you name it
that proudly Proclaim
603 um to put a price tag on it would be
challenging um the Department of
Business and economic Affairs is
undertaking a survey to businesses in
the state to get their thoughts on this
and we expect to have a report on that
from them in June um but he don't
currently have that
information certainly it would
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um in your
testimony you mentioned the
responsibilities of the person hired to
investigate and accomplish this task uh
and yet in the fiscal note um there's it
says does this bill authorize new
positions to implement this bill and and
no is checked so what is it would you
would you need to hire an additional
person to for this bill or not thank you
there would be no additional staff
permanent full-time staff at the
department of energy we issued an RFP
for a consultant to perform that work
and to assist the existing staff at the
department in these actions followup
followup um and you also just mentioned
about the The Branding and the marketing
of 603 would a company still be able to
use 603 as a branding option even though
we had more than one uh ZIP code uh not
zip code area
code so I don't know that I'm the best
qualified person to to answer what their
marketing strategy might be if we had a
second area code and and where they
felt value was in continuing to use that
603 Brands representative licki uh thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question actually I've got two questions
uh one easy one is is nanpa go back to
the days of Mel and are still doing the
same fossilized thing that they did
then I'm not familiar with what Nampa
did one in the days of marel I confess
um but the North American numbering plan
administrator has been around since 1947
when the whole numbering structure okay
was um adopted there have been huge
technological changes since then and NAA
has had to keep up with that and adopted
strategies as has the FCC okay and the
second one I've got the document here
and I know that it's not from you but
from
necta saying that there are by my
addition they have approximately a
million customers in New Hampshire since
we have 10 million possible numbers that
means they're running at 10% efficiency
would you
agree so de
is
not ubiquitous that's the wrong word
necta lines is not representative of all
the lines that are used in the ham it's
only for the residents and businesses
that choose to
use their companies services so they
represent Comcast for example or comcast
is part of necta for example
um if you're not a Comcast customer
you're not going to be in that 1 million
count okay let's try to wrap this up
representative rolds you get the last
question thank you Mr chairman just a
quick question here do you have any
sense of how many or like the percentage
of 603 numbers are fax numbers and with
this um effort involved trying to sort
of recover those you know it's kind of a
somewhat still used but um almost bygone
technology now uh that's a great
question fax numbers and paging numbers
are um certainly numbers that are no
longer uh really used
and but yet they're still assigned to
those carriers and so that's part of
this effort to reclaim those numbers is
to get those blocks of numbers back um
and I I do understand from our friends
in Maine that that um it that effort
alone extended the life of their area
code by at least two to three
years so great question all right well
thank you very much for being here I'm
going to close the public hearing on
house uh Senate Bill
603 and because we're so far behind I'm
going to quickly open the public hearing
on Senate Bill
386 and ask Senator avard to uh
introduce the bill to
us thank you for being here and waiting
patiently Senator I know you're a busy
man we appreciate
that so the floor is yours thank you sir
thank you Mr chairman hopefully this is
an easy bill for you
um in my second term I was uh told that
I'm going to be the chair of
energy and I remember walking into that
room and looking at
everybody and I did a Maya Copa I had no
clue about energy period nothing
zilch and now that I've uh been a few
years uh engaged with this particular
committee uh it's like growing up in a
house where everybody's speaking French
you understand it but you can't speak
it and uh I'm pretty much at that stage
uh I understand when people are coming
and they they have some complex uh
issues and uh so um but one of the
things that I did that that first year
is I put in a bill was it was a study
bill and it had to do with uh
transmission generation and
distribution and so
I uh I learned that now there's a thing
called storage and so what I did is i i
i revamped this this old study and uh
and I added storage to it now why did I
do that well in my committee there are
three individuals that have never sat on
energy and uh I don't know if you know
rep uh Cliff
Belo well I was very smart man and this
is a compliment to to Cliff a very smart
man however as he was going through uh
topics as though just about everybody in
the committee understood what he was
saying uh I could see uh individuals
wanting to uh choose to listen to a
board being scratched with finger nails
then then because they had no idea what
he was talking about um I could grasp
some of the things Senator Waters was
there and by between the both of us we
could uh we could glean what Cliff was
saying and we definitely appreciate his
input uh no SL on him but what uh what I
I I saw was that there was a a lack of
institutional knowledge and as our you
know our legislature changes from year
to year and the changes in energy
whether it's a new department or whether
there's new phrases or new new things
going on I thought it was a good idea to
uh to put in another study committee and
that's really what this is it's it's a
study committee and hopefully I'll chair
it and uh if you uh
if the speaker seems uh
wise has has a an inclination as to who
who could benefit from this I think uh
that would be
great and let the Departments come in
and share the new technologies new
information and uh get people up to
speed what what are the changes because
in four years A lot has changed and so
this is just uh you know something that
is bipartisan and it'll help everybody
get an understanding uh what's happened
what what's changed uh you know where
does the power come from what are the
big fat power lines what are the little
ones what's distribution what is uh
generation and now what is storage and
uh so it'll it'll investigate those
things and hopefully we can come out
with uh some uh some useful information
that we can use in the next
legislature okay thank you so I served
on that study committee as you will no
doubt recall oh and we amassed a huge
amount of information
about generation transmission and
distribution we didn't do storage
obviously but I'm
wondering is it necessary to go over all
that ground again why not just do a
study on
storage uh if if the committee seems
that that's where they want to go that's
fine I do think though that there are
newbies that are that come in that could
possibly benefit from uh including the
interns when they come in uh if I have a
new assistant I asked them to to go back
to that old report and read it uh so
that they can uh come up to speed to
what's going on in in energy and uh it's
up to you I mean I I I think it would be
beneficial but it wouldn't hurt my
feelings if you just kept it the storage
but that's up to you okay additional
questions representative Corman thank
you Mr chairman and thank you again
Senator aart uh just a very simple
question uh I see that the bill says
that the committee reports its findings
by November 1st 2024 but I don't see
anything about uh repealing the
committee so um is this committee
intended to continue beyond November 1st
nope thank
you okay additional questions
representative
Kennedy uh thank you Mr chairman and
thanks for taking my question uh I'm
just wondering whether it wouldn't be
more efficient to Simply have the
department of energy prepare a report
I mean those are the people who are
supposed to be experts here and then any
intern or whoever you would want to get
up to speed could simply read that
report yeah I I think there's something
unique about a study committee though uh
especially when I run it I'm good at it
and U I think you can draw out certain
things and have different departments
and if there might be uh industries that
want to come in and testify about you
know say you just did storage you know
we can have a host of individuals come
in and and talk about that um I'm not
going to waste anybody's time when it
comes to doing a a study committee I
generate
results representative Ms has a question
thank you thank you Senator over here oh
there you are hey how are you
um um why why
couldn't um if if the if the idea is to
is to educate um members of the senate
committee and this committee why
couldn't um people just be invited to
come in for a hearing and and share the
information that they have I mean if you
as the chair of the Senate energy
committee invited industry to come in
and talk about storage I'm sure that you
would have a room full of people and
that would be accomplish what I think is
the objective of educating people it's
partly but there is something unique
about having a study committee and
having a final report and what what we
can do with that is we can uh it keeps
the narrative going as to far whatever
whatever's coming up whatever we we
we've develop and uh future legislation
uh fixes in legislation it's uh it's a
it's Unique to have a study committee uh
and there are some advantages that I
think that I've I've seen over the years
as a direct result of that uh things
that you haven't thought of yeah
somebody can present something to you
that's great but uh as somebody comes in
and testifies you can come back and and
we can explore something maybe in a
different avenue that we hadn't thought
about before uh thinking outside the box
so I uh I do like study committees I I
really don't think they're a waste of
time and uh and I don't think it's also
redundant I do think that uh in in
addition to that when you're engaging
people into questioning coming back a
few
times they're engaged in the process and
they learn a little bit more uh other
than just sitting listening to a lecture
if you will
Vice chair Thomas has a question thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um again kind of a similar
question but I'll just reoriented I know
that the pandemic really messed up our
process here and we have not recovered
fully yet but I know that in the past we
used to have um presentations from
various departments here for the express
purpose of getting our new people up to
speed on what was going on to me that
seems like a more
continuous uh renewal of in of of
information every every two years versus
a study committee which could present a
stagnant report uh would couldn't you
see that as being if we got back to that
process again being a more continuous
and more up toate method of of uh
informing our our new
people you know when I uh when I brought
in that study
bill uh a few years back
I remember walking into the room into
the
house and I a particular state
representative said I'm not going to
teach him anything I remember hearing
her say that she became a very good
friend after that and even we're on the
opposite sides of the aisle and I really
gleaned from that and I gleaned because
she had kind of the same attitude but
she was huge in in helping us out with
uh you know with with information
and they brought in some type of
bipartisan thing that went on there and
I I I can't explain it and that's why
I'm here again I think uh working with
her uh I uh we actually did a signing in
front of the governor and I made sure
that she she got her recognition because
she was very very important to the study
she was an institution as far as I was
concern and I learned a lot from her but
uh I I think that others can do the same
thing and it was it was it was almost
the same kind of objections but I think
we we drew Drew out some good things
from from the study so I um I'm I'm
pretty pretty
uh not adamant but I think it's a really
good idea to have a study yeah if you
don't mind representative McGee has a
question yeah my question is on the
timing of the bill it says at the end
where the report is going to come out
and it gives a November 1 date but it
also says
that the committee should be formed 45
days after passage right so that could
be June so you end up in July and you're
in the summer and it's election year and
you're saying the report is going to be
due not even four full months later
which would mean you'd have maybe a
month per topic so do you think it's an
adequate amount of timing for you to run
a process like this I think if you
narrowed the scope of it yeah maybe if
you just if you just uh brought it down
to uh storage sure yeah
okay thank further questions it's a it's
a huge topic no doubt and uh I think uh
a lot of people you know they they hear
things and they nod their heads but I
guarantee you about 70% of the
information that comes before committees
sometimes people are like I'm really not
sure what he said but I'm nodding my
head it's it can be confusing you know
and uh and I just want people to be up
to speed but uh the Chairman's uh
suggestion maybe just storage I'd be
happy with that
all right Senator seeing no further
questions I want to thank you and having
no further pink cards on this bill I'm
going to close the public hearing on
Senate Bill 396 thank you everybody and
I would now like to open the public
hearing on Senate Bill 449 and call
on uh Senator avard to introduce I mean
Senator Waters to introduce the
legislation
okay uh Senator avard will
introduce Senate Bill 449 relative to
permit the permit issuance timeline for
State air
permits Senator we appreciate it thank
you very much and for the record I'm
Senator Kevin avard filling in for
Senator Waters because I really respect
him a lot I like him uh and so here uh
uh SB 449 relative to permit issuance
timeline for state permits this bill
provides the Comm commissioner 180 days
to act upon air uh Pollution Control
permits
applications that's about it that's
about it
okay so replaces with a reasonable
period of time with 180 days basically
is that
it I uh I I think that's about it I
wasn't prepared to do this but just so
that uh you folks can okay I get it
thanks representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair and I'm not sure you're
going to be able to answer this but um
on lines four and five this would apply
to all sources except affected sources
can you tell me what what that means
except effective effective sources I
would I would defer to to Senator waters
on that thank you the department will be
testifying in a moment so they can
answer that question yes representative
Harrington yeah just answer that
question effective sources means uh
sources that are covered under the
federal Clean Air Act so I'm assuming
and maybe we'll get some more
information on this that it
is anything that doesn't burn anything
or emit anything that would be covered
under the clean era so if you had solar
or wind uh as compared to uh natural gas
Uh Wood coal nuclear power because
nuclear power has permits clean air
permits as well so I think we'd be
limited to those as well as storage
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman okay so the department was
gonna oh here we go so the department
will testify
next thank you
Senator thought you were leaving uh on
us Craig and Mr Wright and maybe some
others will testify for the Department
yes I have a a couple of guys that are
much smarter than me out in the hallway
but I don't see them right now but
anyways um thank you uh I'll just start
off by saying again Craig Wright I serve
as the air director for the Department
of Environmental Services and also with
me today is Todd Moore who just walked
in the door who's in our air permit
program and also Gary Milbury I think Mr
Milbury will join me up here in a second
just a couple of high level comments on
the bill uh first of all Senate Bill 449
is at the request of Dees to deal with
differing timelines between RSA 125c and
r a
541a so I think as you all remember air
permitting is one of the division's most
important functions uh not only under
RSA
125c but also the federal Clean Air Act
um we take that job very seriously and I
think we have an excellent track record
of working with industry on our air
permit
program um one of the fundamental
tenants we need though is sufficient
time to work on air permits uh to review
an air permit application and engage
with app an uh the EPA and the public is
extremely important to us to us to
ensure the integrity and transparen of
the program and with that I was going to
turn it over to Gary I think we have a
testimony letter and Todd could we hand
that out or did we hand that
out sorry we're usually a little more
coordinated than this um this is our
fault because we're so far behind Okay
so the most important thing is um I
think this bill we think would give the
department sufficient time to process
our air permit
applications um and recognizing that
you're so far behind maybe we'll just
keep our testimony to that at this point
I know you're going to hear from the Bia
uh we have been working with Bia on this
bill um I if they have some concerns I
would just like to express to the
committee that we've been working with
them and we would certainly be willing
to continue to work with them um in
terms of finding a place where
everybody's comfortable with this okay
and with that I think we'll just turn it
over to questions I think you get the
gist of what we're talking about yes I
think so so questions for vice chair
Thomas has a question thank you Mr chair
thanks foring my question really really
quick can in the past what was the
reasonable amount of time and was that
longer than 180 days is that where're
making the
change in in some cases uh it it ranged
up to uh I believe nine months for uh a
significant modification to an operating
permit I believe that was the longest
for types of sources we're talking about
here representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so following
up on Vice chair Thomas's question so
the department is actually okay with
putting itself under this time pressure
that it didn't have before this is the
Department's idea put put put the put us
on the clock so essentially what happens
because the way RSA 125 is currently
written it says a reasonable time period
because it doesn't specify a time period
RSA 541
a29 kicks in and that gives us 60 days
which is totally unworkable for us so
we've come up with what we believe to be
a reasonable time period including you
got to realize we have to do we have to
do a completeness review of the air
permit application we have to do a
technical review of the air permit
application we have to draft the permit
and then we also need to go through a
public notice and public hearing
opportunity so if you back calculate all
those chunks of times that's
approximately how we came up with 180
days okay before I call on other
questions I just want want to give
Senator Waters an update Senator while
you were out Senator avard introduced
the bill and you are certainly most
welcome to testify if you so desire but
um since he already introduced the bill
you don't have to if if you don't need
to okay okay thank you sir uh now we'll
move along representative Kaplan first
yeah thank you Mr chair and thanks
thanks for coming in today this might be
the question other people also have
could you clarify what type of uh what
type of installations this deadline
would affect are we talking Title Five
applicants are we
talking uh the uh the amendment that the
uh senate committee approved at their uh
at their initial hearing um was
specifically added to address Title Five
permits which are really those time
frames are more dictated by the federal
Clean Air Act and EPA so uh this bill
would would apply to basically all other
types of permits other than the title 5
operating uh representative
Harrington thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking a question just a follow
up on that the effective sources means
you know covered under the Clean Air Act
but this is a Air Pollution Control
permit so there must be some type of
source that's not covered under the air
um the Clean Air Act but also requires
an air pollution control permit from
Dees what would those be for
example uh so we essentially have um
your affected sources which are defined
in the laws uh sources subject to the
title 5 permitting
program that uh like I said EPA
essentially dictates time frames under
that program so this this would cover uh
basically your non-affected sources
these are generally your smaller sources
that uh might have a uh a heating system
like a like a large boiler uh maybe like
a hospital or um you know smaller
commercial facilities so we're generally
talking um fuel burning devices or small
companies that like manufacturing
companies that may emit uh uh regulated
toxics uh that are covered under 125i
okay thank you represent ative muns has
a question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for coming in and taking my question
um so what is it about um these specific
permits that's so different than the uh
applications and permits that are
considered that are covered by uh RSA
541 where where the requirement is to
have a uh an answer within 60 days so uh
when when that bill was passed I believe
in the 2018 session that essentially
unless specifically Exempted applied to
any type of environmental or any type of
permit that was issued including any
permits issued by
Dees um and as director Wright mentioned
the the issue with the 60 days is that
uh even before we get into any real
detailed
review um the process requires that once
we do complete a review we go out to
public notice uh some programs may you
know if there's a permit of
interest uh you know certain programs
may require say a butter
notification uh this is air pollution so
it's a little unique and therefore under
our programs we need to provide public
notice uh at in a Statewide newspaper
which would be the union leader and then
we
also uh provide a public notice in a
local paper uh as close to the applicant
town as we
can as you know there are challenges
with newspapers either closing or
reducing to going to a weekly so uh
anyways those notices have have to uh be
for a minimum of 30 days once we figure
in the planning it takes lead times to
get it into newspapers and such you're
essentially at 40 days and we haven't I
haven't mentioned any work that we've
actually done Rev doing the application
so it essentially gave
us regardless of you know uh you know
the uh level of activity and or number
of applications coming in regardless of
the
complexity we essentially had that
60-day time frame to review every one of
those applications and get out to
notice um if somebody requests a hearing
we have to go out for an additional
30-day notice so that's that's what made
the 60 days unworkable for the air
permit program and that's where we've
asked for uh you know for a uh the 180
day time frame um and then we We There
is a provision where we can work with
applicants uh and uh request more time
if something does need more time so that
we can do our role in protecting public
health and and do a thorough review of
the application follow followup followup
so
um unless the process for Air permits is
dramatically different than other
permits covered by RSA
541 what you're describing to me would
suggest that the that the limits in 541
need to be changed that they're
unrealistic I I don't want to speak for
other programs there might be some
programs where that don't have those
types of uh public comment periods that
we may have um the requirements may be
simpler so there there may be
opportunities for other permits uh that
can be processed in that amount of time
I will point out a couple things that
the air division has done specific to
air
permitting um where we have reduced
turnaround times one of those is we've
established a general permit for sources
that are installing backup generators
for backup power uh we have an online
registration uh where the permit is
established every 5 years
and instead of going out and going
through the typical
process we've set up what's called the
general permit where facilities that
have backup engines can uh actually
register those engines and obtain their
permit through an online process and
we've reduced that where uh generally a
permit can be issued anywhere from you
know a couple days to a couple weeks
turnaround time that's one and we've
also got a permit by notification
program for uh sand and gravel sources
for Rock crushing and screening
equipment where it's a online
registration and uh portable crushing
plants uh can also use the online system
to notify us uh if they're moving to a
new location so if complaints are
received we can follow up at that
address so we those are a couple
examples where we've been able to look
at certain types of very simple types of
permits and Implement a a permitting
system that is uh where 60 days would
would work for that but um this the 541a
my un 29 my understanding is that that
would cover uh different types of uh
permit programs within the department
some that might be an appropriate limit
but um at Le for at a minimum for the
traditional air permitting programs it's
just not workable so I
I um my experience I I I'd hate to go
out and say
UH 60 days doesn't work for anything
there might be programs where it does I
apologize for long-winded response but I
wanted a couple examples
followup than thank you just one one
quick followup is is some of the um the
pressure that you feel to get these done
within the time frame is that is that
because of some resource constraints
where you you don't have the staff you
don't have the the the technology
infrastructure
Etc I love always ask for more resources
for uh you know to increase timeliness
of Permitting um I think I think we try
to uh you know balance the resources we
try to balance uh shifts and economic
activity uh for example April is a month
where we tend to receive a lot of
applications for construction uh
sometimes the late winter months as well
so that they can go through the process
and have their permit to uh do the
construction during the Spring and
Summer um
yeah you the only thing I would add
about resources is is the entire
permitting program is paid by the
applicants the regulated Community they
pay the fees that run the program so if
I wanted more resources I would need to
raise those fees and I don't think that
would be very popular in this
environment okay additional questions
representative Harrington um yeah sort
of like the thing that's not mentioned
here we have the 100 not to exceed 180
days for everything except for Effective
sources which we've established as there
covered under the Clean Air Act what's
the time limit on those apparently
there's none I mean could be five years
10 years or up to a year
right
excuse do in some cases it's could be up
to a year correct
that covers different tyes of
per this is Todd speaking work
Gary so there are some time frames I
know one year for title Ral for initial
permit 18
months pment
NSR so it varies I guess my question
would be since we're changing the law to
address the time frame shouldn't we
include something for quote affected
sources whether that's if 180 days is
what you're saying is not sufficient
because of all the federal hoopla I
understand that but maybe 365 days is
days or something so there's a limit on
it thank you both of those references in
the statute refer to 40 CFR part 70 and
there are timelines specified in that
section and one of them is nine months
and one of them is longer than nine
months they're at the federal level so
we can't
change okay further questions
representative
Kennedy yeah I think you partly answered
this but when I look at the Senate
testimony there was a lot of concern by
small businesses that basically 180 days
is too long and I get the feeling that
someone at Dees said well if the if the
application is simple or small then will
work faster so I don't know if that's
comforting enough for them or whether
something specific needs to be try to
put into the
bill so we have had ongoing discussions
with Bia I don't want to characterize
those totally today other than they have
expressed some concerns about the one
siiz fits-all with the 180 days um so
that's something we're certainly willing
to have ongoing discussions with E A
subcommittee or a work session or and
with Bia of
course well the text on line five says
within a re reasonable period of time
and does not exceed 180 days so that
would make me to believe that it could
be done in fewer than 180 days is that
not true that that's correct chair
uh uh tradition so I I will also kind of
break air permits that we're talking
about today into kind of two categories
there are permits for like a a new new
installation or modification to
equipment at a existing permited
facility we those are considered our top
priority in terms of how uh how quickly
they come in in the
prioritization and then you have
operating permits that uh that the
source ultimately gets after a
construction permit and those are good
for a 5year period And when those come
up for Renewal uh there are Provisions
in air permit programs uh basically
every state in EPA programs uh have a
provision called application Shield
where if your permit is up for Renewal
if you file a timely application um the
sources we're talking about today if you
file a renewal 90 days before the
expiration date of your permit you keep
operating under the terms and conditions
of your permit until we can take action
on those renewals so in general what
happens and this may speak to some of
the questions we got uh you know when
when when we're prioritizing
applications for processing your new
construction and modification
applications get the highest
priority um we generally try to get
those complete um our our goal is is 120
days
max
um so we we we do have an internal goal
to uh focus on those and then what ends
up happening is if there is a resource
issue or uh all of a sudden there's a
lot of uh economic activity where we're
getting a lot of requests to build
something um those renewals will
ultimately get pushed off a little bit
so that we make sure we meet our goals
on the higher priority
applications okay excellent
representative Ros has a question yes
again one pretty quick I hope uh I know
you won't have exact numbers but um how
many permits of the type that are
contemplated by this bill uh are in
existence now how many permits are out
there you know how many sources and then
how many new ones um do you see each
year just ballpark uh well just uh I'll
separate out the the the one the backup
generators that I mentioned uh that they
can register online we have over 400 of
those um Todd would you say other than
the affected we have about 35 affected
sources that we're exempting or
proposing to have not covered on of this
that leaves us uh is it about
sources looking at some of the
information the program put together
about 60 applications on the new
construction significant Amendment which
of the one is
concerned and then on top of that we're
doing renals
that Shield so the applicant is not
waiting for the decision to change their
operations so 60 of the ones that the
applicant is really concerned about and
then in addition to that we
do sure how many more RS and then all
thetive not
cover I I believe we get somewhere
around is it safe to say we get around
maybe 120 to30 applications a
year uh and and uh like Todd said about
60 of those are ones that we would be
placing a higher priority on and then
the balance uh we would work into
our
processing uh
schedule representative lewicki has a
question okay thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question what
triggers the need for an a permit um is
it some level of uh emissions or is it
uh you
know sure cuz you know my home generator
shouldn't be no uh in general you we we
don't permit
residential uh residences at all it it's
essentially your commercial
institutional industrial facilities that
uh require an air permit so uh an
example
um uh if you uh have a say a a boiler or
furnace That's
rated um over over uh
that that burns natural gas or number
two oil that's over 10 million BTUs per
hour which is a rating on the furnace
that requires an air permit just for
reference the one you have in your home
is probably around 100,000 BTUs per hour
um mine at home is like 90 I've seen
them up to
125,000 so uh the boilers that are
running on like essentially home heating
oil or natural gas or propane uh they
would have to be uh over 10 million BTUs
so roughly 100 times bigger uh and then
we have um and then if there were C like
if it if it operates on wood because of
the emissions a permit's needed if it's
over 2 million BTUs per hour still about
20 times bigger than your typical
furnace uh we uh diesel engines that are
for non-emergency
purpose uh some uh uh wood process
processing industry you know Sawmills
and such uh uh use generators uh uh for
for uh Prime power uh to operate their
facilities um you'll see uh you know
places like uh most of your hospitals
have air permits for their heating
systems um uh St Paul's School in
conquered another you know larger
facility that would would require a
permit so uh so engines and boilers for
fuel burning devices and then
manufacturing facilities
um they're subject to the state air
toxics law so that's kind of a chemical
by chemical review to see if a permit's
needed um uh fuel storage
facilities
um uh incineration units um for
municipal waste um most of your larger
landfills because they require uh
landfill gas control systems to be
installed and
managed um those are those are a number
of examples of the types of facilities
that our our our power plants around the
state
um
okay seeing no further questions for the
Department I want to thank you three
gentlemen for being here today to help
us understand this bill we have one more
pink card and we're going to hear next
from the business and industry
Association and ksten kooch is going to
tell us why the Bia opposes this
legislation good
morning and welcome nice to see you
again good morning chairman Vose members
of the committee it's still morning
right um I'll be brief I know it's been
a long morning um for the record my name
is Kirsten kotch I'm the vice president
of public policy for the business and
industry Association we serve as uh New
Hampshire Statewide Chamber of Commerce
known as Bia uh firstly I'd like to
recognize
um that the Department of Environmental
Services has been exceptionally
cooperative and has been having ongoing
discussions with Bia staff and members
about the need for this change um biia
fully recognizes as and is in support of
the Department's need for this change um
we understand that there needs to be a
more realistic permit application
timeline as well as the need to
reconcile the conflicting statutes um
however B is opposed to Senate Bill 449
as currently
drafted the bill provides the
commissioner 100 80 days to act upon an
air pollution control permit application
this is three times longer than the
current timeline of 60 days um this
drastic change in timeline and the
Optics are especially concerning for our
members that are new and small
businesses um their
operations um hinge on the timely
approval of permits um as many of you
already know it has long been a priority
of the Bia to advocate for streamlining
Expediting the regulatory
process um we believe the larger problem
that this bill attempts to address is
that the state has enacted an ambitious
regulatory agenda um while the
department is challenged by a lack of
resources necessary to administer and
keep up with these changes the recurring
solution for this problem seems to be
giving the state agencies more time to
make permitting decisions um however
this solution is not a financially
sustainable practice for business and
industry business's success relies on
regulatory reliability and
predictability undue delay on projects
unfairly burdens Property Owners
developers ultimately killing projects
because in many cases the state has not
yet committed the necessary resources
for the agencies to in a reasonable time
frame
uh I'm sorry um administer the statutes
and rules it's adopted um while the perv
while it is the purview of the state
legislator to decide how aggressively it
wants to regulate regulate Environmental
Protection the amount of funding it
wants to devote to it we ask please not
to shift the burden of untimely
decisions onto the businesses and
Property Owners um we do have a few
recommendations um we believe that if
state agencies cannot meet the deadline
and statute then applicant should
receive the default approvals as
provided in RSA 541 829 um we see this
as a guarantee for accountability on the
dep part of the department although
that's not our preference we'd rather
they get the correct approval um to
further improve this bill be our
preference to work with the Department
to draft an amendment to establish dual
tracks for air permit timelines um so
whereas more complex permits would have
longer timelines less complex permits
would have shorter timelines moreover we
believe that there needs to be um
protections for new and small businesses
whose viability relies on these timely
permitting um decisions I know the
department has made comments about um
you know prioritizing new and small
businesses and and we appreciate that
and and we do believe that will happen
but we'd like to see that enshrined in
statute to guarantee that that um stays
a practice going forward and finally um
because this bill proposes a lengthy
extension and timeline we'd like to see
the extensions beyond the established
timelines removed um in conclusion um
it's important to us that any changes
made to this bill would be realistic and
workable for both industry and the
department um we respectfully request
the committee allow more time for
industry and the department to work
together on crafting an amendment so
that's bill um that is necessary can
pass um with the right compromises going
forward thank you I'd be happy to answer
any
questions well thank you appreciate your
input on this legislation questions from
Miss K representative Corman thank you
Mr chairman and thank you Miss KO for
taking my question um I I understand the
the idea of of the Dual tracks I'm
wondering is it really feasible to
establish in statute the actual criteria
for the Dual tracks thank you for the
question um that's something we've been
discussing with the department and I
think um our engineers and our
membership are reviewing as well um it's
something we like to work on going
forward with the
Department follow up yeah I'm just
wondering does it make more sense to
have it as a rul making rather than in
statute um thank you for the question I
think that's probably a decision for the
committee to
decide representative Kennedy has a
question
yeah thank you Mr chairman it's just
very similar I mean I guess you are not
totally comforted by we will do it
faster so you do have a plan for
adjusting the bill and um you know I I I
had the same thought as uh
representative Corman that maybe that
could be put into a
rule okay uh further questions
representative
Harrington and thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question um
first one what's going on now have a
60-day limmit they want an extension for
tripling that amount of time so I assume
most permits aren't issued within 60
days I think it thank you for the
question um so I think first there's a
problem with conflicting statute there's
one statute that says this needs to be
done in a reasonable amount of time and
there's one statute that says this needs
to be done in 60 days and I it's my
understanding that most of these permits
or at least the more complex ones cannot
be done in 60 days
followup followup now you've listed a
different a number of things here uh is
Bia prepared to give something that
could be implemented this session or are
you basically saying let's put this on
hold get back with the department and
come up with some way to implement these
proposals that will isn't going to be
able to be done in the next few weeks is
that accurate statement uh thank you for
the question uh we're prepared to work
on Amendment with the Department this
week I mean it's something that we can
we're already discussing we can do this
right away um so we'd like to have an
amendment ready for the committee very
soon all right thank you uh
representative Kaplan has a
question that was B thank you Mr chair
that was basically my question but I
guess I ask you did you run out of time
when in your discussions with the
Department is that why you need extra
time in order to do this thank you for
the question um you know I think this
bill when it was in the Senate it flew
through the committee it was voted on
the same day that um the public hearing
was immediately after and so we thought
there may be an opportunity to do
something like this in the Senate
unfortunately there just wasn't the time
to do
it representative Ms has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank thank you
for coming in and I I I want to thank
you for um highlighting the fact that a
lack of resources is at least a part of
the problem um because I think that is
um an important
consideration um and and the the only
thing that I I guess I would ask is that
um if you're working with the Department
on a um an amendment which is wonderful
um give some please give some
consideration to how do we how we
address that resource um uh constraint
um including how we pay for it thank you
thank you additional comments
representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Miss kooch for
being here today um I just want to note
that we already heard that on the other
side of the wall there's a lot of pretty
fa is there so maybe they didn't have
any questions for you but we do um in
the testimony from the um from the
Department of Environmental Services uh
air division air quality division they
mentioned some of the statutory
requirements that they're required to
meet in order to process some of these
complex or new applications including
application completeness a technical
review public notice um all of which
take Literal time
and then you know crafting and issuing
the permits so I agree that there may be
resource issues in terms of there being
a a choke point that only certain people
are doing that work but um I I still am
not
sure uh I'm not sure about the
conclusion that there aren't
circumstances under which a six-month
period would be needed for a particular
permit and that they might be able to
decide
that um thank you for that I don't think
that we dispute that there are some
cases where there's more time needed um
especially on very complex projects and
when they need to do the public
notification requirements um our goal
here is to come up with a timeline
that's reasonable for both industry and
the department and we don't want to
suggest anything that creates a
condition that they can't work
under thank
you additional questions from Miss KO
seeing none I want to thank you very
much for um giv giving us your
perspective on this legislation and I'll
look forward to hearing how Amendment
negotiations go thank you with an idea
toward there being extremely
timely it's possible that we may exec
this bill a week from today Monday the
22nd of April so I'll just throw that
out there in case that helps uh move
things
along okay um with that we're going to
close the public hearing on Senate Bill
449 and we will now take an extended
lunch break I know some of our
Democratic colleagues have another
meeting they need to go to the uh
Republican members of this committee
will hang back in the room for a caucus
and we'll see the rest of uh you at 2:00
for exec session thank you very
much
e
e e
time to resume st's session for April
15th of 2024 this afternoon we're here
to
conduct executive session on five bills
Senate Bill 303 Senate Bill 388 Senate
Bill 391 Senate Bill 451 and Senate Bill
54 so I'm going to open an exec session
on Senate Bill 303
and uh I'm going to recognize
representative n for a moer thank you Mr
chairman I move ought to pass chair
recognizes representative Harrington I
second that motion moved and seconded
that
we adopt the motion of ought to pass on
Senate Bill
303 and I'd like to open the floor to
comments on the
motion anybody have anything to say
okay in that case U I will just point
out that this bill is essentially was
requested by the department of energy
and is a bill to clarify the use of
monies that flow into the renewable
energy
fund and it makes uh the Department's
use of those funds clarifies the
Department's use of those funds to
achieve the purposes of
maximizing the benefit of renewable
energy especially with regard to
lowincome solar and other lowincome
projects is there any further discussion
on this
bill well seeing none I'd ask the clerk
to call the role on the question of
ought to pass on Senate Bill
303 Vice chair
Thomas yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Lei yes representative
Melvin yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee yes representative
MC Williams
yes representative parshall yes
representative Kaplan yes repres
representative muns yes representative
Noel yes representative Thomas yes
representative Corman yes representative
rolds yes chairman Vose yes
190 okay by a vote of 19 to zero the
committee adopts the motion of ought to
pass on Senate Bill
38 without objection we'll put this bill
on the consent calendar
you want to introduce Charlie M okay so
I forgot at the beginning of this
session to introduce representative
Charlie Melvin who is sitting in this
afternoon for Lex Berney thank you for
being here Charlie appreciate
it who is um who is missing that oh
representative cran is okay all right
thank you the report so representative n
will write the uh committee report for
Senate Bill
308 and with that we'll close that exact
session and now we'll open an exec
session on Senate Bill
FN and I am going to move ought to pass
on Senate Bill
388 as amended by Amendment 2024 14968
which is circulating in your direction
even as I
speak and while you are awaiting the
arrival of the printed copy of the
amendment which was provided to all of
you electronically last
Friday I will point out that this also
is a bill that was requested by the
department of energy and uh what this
bill essentially does is that it
clarifies um
the net metering Community solar project
section of the net metering
statute and adds language about new
solar arrays changes the reference to
homeowners to hous holds which is more
appropriate and add some references to
the fact that uh projects that are ready
to go will receive
uh prefer pref refence by the
department representative Thomas uh you
you need to get a second oh I sorry I
didn't get a second okay so uh I
recognize representative Thomas second
moved and
seconded now we're I'm going to amove
the adoption of amendment 2024 1496 and
I recognize Vice chair Thomas second
okay now now we can discuss the
amendment so the last thing that the or
the other thing that the amendment does
is
it adds the text by rule or order in two
places uh under RSA 362 F colon 2
paragraph
15a This is
the um RSA that we modified last year to
bifurcate small and
large um Bo
boiler boilers for their qualification
for Rex and uh the department realized
after that legislation was passed that
they really needed this extra text and
so they've asked asked us to include
that and the uh Amendment does just that
so with that I'll see if there's any um
comments that anyone has to make about
the amendment
representative Thomas thank you U Mr
chair I just wanted to um clarify the by
rule or order so can you just tell me
what the order it who the order would
come from is that an executive
order no that is a department of energy
order so if there is a
proceeding within the department of
energy that makes some kind of a
decision they typically in issue an
order codifying that decision the puc
does the same thing and other agencies
probably as well thank
you further
discussion seeing none I ask the clerk
to call the role on the question of the
adoption of the amendment 2024 D1
14968 Vice chair Thomas yes
representative ner yes representative
Harrington yes representative Mii yes
representative Melvin yes representative
bernardy yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee yes representative
McWilliams yes representative parshall
yes representative Kaplan yes
representative muns yes representative
Noel yes representative Thomas yes
representative Corman yes representative
rolds yes chairman Vos yes
190 by vote of 19 to nothing the
amendment is adopted I now move ought to
pass as amended and recognize Vice chair
Thomas second moved and seconded that we
adopt the motion of ought to pass as
amended for Senate Bill 388
as amended by Amendment 1496 H any
further discussion
needed seeing none I ask the clerk to
call the role on the question of ought
to pass as amended by amendment number
1496 h on Senate Bill
388 Vice chair Thomas yes representative
nder yes representative Harrington yes
representative Wicky yes
representative Melvin yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative
McGee yes representative MC Williams yes
representative parshall yes
representative Kaplan yes representative
muns yes representative Noel yes
representative Thomas yes representative
Corman yes representative rolds yes yes
chairman Vose yes
190 okay by a vote of 19 to Zer the
committee adopts the motion about to
pass as
amended as amended
by amendment number 1496 H and I will
write the committee
report and without objection we'll put
this on the consent
calendar seeing no objection it goes on
to
consent
and with that we'll close that executive
session and next we'll open an executive
session on Senate Bill
391 and the chair recognizes rep
representative McGee for a
motion yes I'd like to make a motion of
ought to pass as
amended and I will second that aemotion
that
motion I think I just uh recited a song
lyric didn't
I so chair recognizes uh representative
McGee for a motion on an
amendment yes I'd like to make a motion
of ought to pass on Amendment uh 2024
D14
91h and I second that
motion so it has been moved and seconded
that we adopt amendment number
H
and if you so desire representative
McGee I'll give you first crack at
discussing the amendment if not I'll do
that
myself go ahead okay so what this
amendment does is it adds three key
things to the original bill on line
three uh excuse me line five it adds
text that says within 60 days of the
effective date of this section the
department of energy shall open a
proceeding so that the text within 60
days of the effective date of this
session is
new and then online
starting uh Midway through line
nine and going down to Midway through
line 12 there's new text that says the
department shall provide the
chairpersons of the house science
technology and energy committee and the
Senate energy and natural resources
committee with status updates regarding
the proceeding every six months after
opening the proceeding until rules are
adopted by the department so that's new
text and essentially that will allow our
committee and the senate in our
committee to keep tabs on this
proceeding to make sure that it stays on
track and then the final new text is on
line
18 actually it starts at the very end of
17 and it adds and shall be submitted to
the Joint legislative committee on
administrative rules within 15 months of
the effective date of this section so
essentially what that says is that this
proceeding should not take any longer
than 15 months it doesn't have to take
15 months but 15 months is the longest
it should take so those are the uh
changes that the
amendment uh makes to the original
legislation anybody have comments on
those changes are on the
amendment representative McGee thank you
Mr chairman yeah I'll just say that um
you know the the need for rules and the
discussions around the issues that were
having with interconnection in the state
were totally uncontested in the in the
hearings um what was at issue was the
time scale that people would have to be
facing um moving forward and that was
where there was you know push and pull
in terms of what could be delivered and
what time frame and um you know how
aggressive we could be in trying to at
least get the rules established so that
the interconnection cues could start to
be um dealt with in a in
a um a more consistent way and and
hopefully a shorter time frame so the
one of the things that we contended with
was um when we would require the rules
to be delivered and uh the negotiations
actually started at 18 months which um
there are quite a few people in the
queue who've been waiting quite a
significant amount of time now so we
wanted to be mindful of what the
department of energy felt they needed in
terms of their resources and how they're
approaching this rules process um and so
the compromise was made really you know
they say the best compromises are
nobody's happy that is this bill or this
amendment so that's that's all I have to
say thank you additional comments
representative Ms thank you Mr chair um
well I while I think it's it's great
that um there are some defined timelines
um identified um uh and that's a real
positive in in terms of this amendment
it it is disappointing that um the way
the bill or the way the amendment is
written doesn't really um take advantage
of what hopefully has been a lot of
discussion and dialogue that's been
going on around this issue uh the fact
that the amendment is worded so that uh
the proceeding will start 60 days after
the effective date of the uh the bill um
it just seems like an artificial delay
and um I would have liked to have seen a
little bit more urgency in um in moving
things forward um hopefully um uh if we
pass this today which I suspect we will
hopefully the department will take that
as a sign that this is going to move
forward and they will start and they
will get started on on actually moving
this issue forward because it's a it's a
major issue that that businesses and
homeowners across the state have uh
Express concern about and we really need
to address
it I agree that this is a significant
issue I do 100
per. and you guys are going to think I'm
weird for bringing this up but this
morning I actually looked at RSA 541a i'
I've read it on numerous occasions in
the past but I hadn't looked at it for a
couple of
years and I looked at it to kind of just
refresh my memory on just what is
involved in the process of drafting
rules and among the things that I was
reminded of by
reading uh RSA
541a is that before you start a rule
proceeding you actually have to notify
the public you have to put out a notice
that you're going to start a rules
proceeding and it has to be 30 days I
believe or maybe even 60 days before the
proceeding begins and then once the
proceeding once the the the drafting of
rules has
begun uh and you have some rules to show
to people you actually have to have
public comment periods and all of those
public comment periods take time so to
restrict this proceeding any further
than 15 months I think would be would
make it difficult for the Department to
complete the process according to the
um the
prescribed
legislative procedure that's in the
administrative procedures act so I think
15 months is a reasonable amount of time
to give the department uh the time it
needs to do what it needs to do further
comment on either the amendment or the
bill representative Corman thank thank
you uh it's actually a question on uh
the last sentence in both the original
bill and the amendment any new employee
positions required to implement this
chapter shall be approved by the fiscal
Committee of the general court and I I
forget if we discussed this before does
that mean that the fiscal committee has
no latitude and must approve them or is
it more that they're subject to
approval I personally believe it means
the latter
um but
you're you're preent in bringing that
issue to the Forefront it is a it is an
interesting question Mr shulock would
you like to um give us your opinion
about whether that
sentence uh means that if the department
goes to the fiscal committee and says we
need another position they have to give
it to
you and could you come forward to
respond to that thank
you I'll give you a lawyerly answer I
don't know if they're constitutionally
required to give it to us but I expect
that they would if they believe that we
needed
it so basically you're saying if you
make a good case that you need that
person then you'll probably get it well
there there is a reason why we keep
arguing for more time to do this we we
are a resource constrained
so okay that answer the question for you
representative Corman uh as well as
possible okay further comment on this
thank you Mr
shulock further comment on the
amendment seeing none I ask the clerk to
call the role in the question of the
adoption of amendment 20249 1491
H Vice chair Thomas yes representative
ner yes representative Harrington yes
representative lii yes representative
Melvin yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee yes representative
MC
Williams yes representative
parshall yes representative Kaplan yes
representative mun
yes representative Noel yes
representative Thomas yes representative
Corman yes representative rolds yes
chairman Vose yes
190 by a vote of 19 to zero the
amendment is
adopted
and representative McGee I recognize her
for an ad for a motion
otpa yes I'll make a motion for otpa I
second the motion of otpa is there any
further discussion
needed seeing none I'll ask the clerk as
soon as he has his paperwork ready to
call the role on the question of ought
to pass as amended by Amendment 1491 H
Senate Bill 391
Vice chair Thomas yes representative ner
yes representative Harrington yes
representative licki yes representative
Melvin yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Kennedy
no representative McGee yes
representative mcwells yes
representative parshall yes
representative Kaplan yes representative
muns yes representative Noel yes
representative Thomas yes representative
Corman yes representative rolds yes
chairman Vose yes
181 okay by a vote of 18 to one the
committee adopts
the motion of ought to pass is amended
on Senate Bill 391 as amended by
Amendment
1491 and representative McGee will write
the committee
report and without objection I'll put
this on the consent
calendar hearing no objection it goes on
to consent
so we'll close the executive session on
Senate Bill
now let's open an exec session on Senate
Bill
451 and I have some Amendment texts to
pass out here to
people okay
so the chair recognizes representative
Thomas for a
motion thank you Mr chair um motion
OTP
otpa oh we haven't done the amendment am
first so it should be OTP at
first have to pass the amendment first
no we have to open up
for we have to open I always get
confused by this are you supposed to to
move OTP
otpa move the amendment first OTP then
you introduce the amendment OTP on the
amend okay
so representative Thomas moves ought to
pass on Amendment 1501
H and representative
Harrington is
recognized have a here we go I have a
question I have haven't had much chance
I need a second first oh okay well I'm
not seconding representative Bernardi is
recognized I second the motion moved in
second it now representative Harrington
try this again um on page three of the
amendment on line starting at line 30
All State agencies having permitting or
regulatory Authority shall make and
submit the committee a final decision on
parts of the application that relate to
their permitting and other regulatory
functions no later than 120 days after
the application's been accept it we just
heard a bill this morning saying that
air permits weren't going to be required
for 180 days so it sounds like
something's in Conflict here that's what
the dees said they needed to have so
since air permits could be a part of
something that uh is covered by this
bill um we seem to have a conflict here
and this also says within 180 days of
the acceptance of the application the
committee shall issue would deny a
certificate for energy facility again if
the air permit is going to take 180 days
that see how the committee can finish it
on the same day that they get that now I
realized there's a caveat at the end
that says something to the
effect um times for conducting public
hearings ring a decision on the
application may be extended for good
cause upon written request of the
applicant it doesn't say anything about
the committee being able to extend that
date so if we're going to have 180 days
for ear permits we can't say you have to
have them done in 120 days one of those
has got to
give well I assume that this is
referring
to the application before the site
evaluation committee I have to differ
All State agencies having permanent or
other regulatory Authority that includes
Dees issuing an a
permit yes I understand
that but this particular legislation
refers to the site evaluation
committee and
if my my memory
serves elsewhere in the SEC legislation
and I don't have the entire Statute in
front of
me it basically says that All State
agencies uh having permitting or other
regulatory Authority have to make and
submit to the
committee a final decision on the parts
of the application that relate to its
permitting
with a longer time frame this only
applies to the FastTrack section of this
legislation and so it does shorten the
time frame now will that conflict with
the bill that we just passed earlier I
don't know I don't know the answer to
that and there's nobody from Dees here
who could shed any light on that
question Mr
yes um Dees was party to the discussions
around the changes that would happen in
the FasTrack bill for the SEC process
for existing facilities for that are
being repur repurposed and they did
provide input on that um so I I think
that was part of the reason that the
language towards the end was listed that
for a good reason in writing if you know
somebody had to have a delay they could
but I think they are trying to hold to
um a tighter process because they think
that it'll only be in exceptional cases
where
um the example that was given in our
meeting was that if we were looking at
converting to say a hydrogen um facility
you would need the Army Corps of
Engineers and they would not be able to
turn that around in a tight time frame
because there's there's a you know
there's a um a base time limit that you
get with that particular interaction but
in most cases they didn't think um that
the permiting time frame would be
elongated because in many cases the
plants would be um probably
less of less concern in terms of the
technologies that they're turning
towards um that was the only example
they could really think of where it
would probably be a more extensive uh
effort in terms of the per in
process
yes I I think it's a good catch by
representative Harrington and I wonder
if Mr shulock if you would have any
comment on a potential conflict
between language in Cate Bill 449 which
we heard this earlier today that wants
to give air PR emitting 180 days versus
the language here that wants to limit it
to 120 days
so I'm not familiar with the other bill
I can say that for these facilities
there is an expectation that most of
them are not going to require air
permits right that the for the most part
the projects that are expected to be
developed uh over the next several years
will be renewable facilities right and
so that specific conflict shouldn't be a
problem but there should be language if
I scribed everything and got everything
in theil Emil to to folks correctly
there should be Provisions that allow
for an applicant to to extend the time
right so if if uh DS requires 30 more
days in order to approve a permit then
the applicant would simply request that
extension
yeah yes I believe we saw that uh
language in the in the bill yeah so yeah
there there are plenty of opport unities
to extend if if an applicant needs it
the the SEC sighting wouldn't need to
fill the reason uh for allowing the
applicant to request that extension is
so that outside agencies don't feel the
need to deny a permit within that 180
days just because they can't make it
right so the or the 120 days what
whatever it is right so the the
applicant can simply ask for an
additional amount of time so that their
application doesn't fail before the SEC
okay thank you representative Harrington
does that answer your question not
really that seems to be reverse logic uh
couple of things first renewable covers
wood so we could take a like we did
earlier in New Hampshire and we
converted a I think it was a coal plant
into a wood burning plant it would
require a different air permit whole
different types of missions that would
be renewable and that would require the
air permit that we say they have 180
days to give this says he got to do it
120 and I really don't think we want to
be in the position of of telling
applicants well you're going to be
denied the permit unless we can exceed
the amount of time by law that we're
allowed to look at this because
otherwise we'll just have to deny it
because we don't have enough time to do
it well if you don't have enough time to
do it then you ought to improve the
process or change the law but don't just
say well if you write a letter to us
saying you're requesting an extension
even though you don't want an extension
because it's going to cost you a lot of
money uh but if you do that then we'll
keep working on it and maybe six months
from now you'll get your permit but
otherwise we're going to just deny it
that that doesn't make any sense putting
that in the law that that logic to me I
think this needs more work if I may the
SEC wouldn't be the agency denying it
would be Dees that would say we don't
have enough time right so Dees asked for
the ability for the applicant to
request um the extension without
effectively without a denial right from
from the SEC so that the SEC process and
the dees process could continue in
concert followup that would means why
even have a number in at all because if
the dees decides well it's going to take
six months for this permit because we're
not going to around to it for a while so
you can either have your permit denied
or you can request the six months
extension it it becomes totally
meaningless to put a a number in there
if the recourse of the applicant is to
say oh well you're going to deny the
permit unless I agree to give you more
time then why even bother putting any
kind of a deadline in because it's
totally meaningless I I just think this
needs work it needs to be something
needs to be
fixed representative McGee yeah I was
just going to say I think the reason
that there's a time frame in there is
because all the parties that were there
discussing the bill were the intent of
the bill was to try and um create a
process that would FastTrack repurposing
of existing facilities that had already
already been cited by the evaluation
committee so there would be exceptions
if there were items that needed to be
permitted that were distinct from what
was already at the facility site but the
idea of having a shortened time frame
was really the intent of of having
something in legislature that would be a
separate process from what we did in 609
so um I think that was kind of the
driving force which is why there's a
number in there at least that would be
my explanation that why they're trying
they were trying to quantify it in terms
of how long they wanted the process to
be um sort of the standard process but
then they had to allow for exceptions
because they didn't want people to be
turned away because uh of of a process
that was outside of the norm but they
they wanted to define the norm as being
short a short
process well we could consider changing
the 120 days to 180 days but then we'd
have to change the 180 days on line 33
to some um longer date like 210 days or
something would that be a potential
fix Mr shulock do you have a
comment whether extending the lines
would would fix it I think it would
address
represent Harrington's issues if the
deadlines were extended to accommodate
um the time necessary to Grant an air
permit whether that works for everybody
in the group it's it's not a department
the the department isn't responsible for
the bill we uh helped with the drafting
Etc but um the the people who would like
who are or
um supporting the bill um um may have
something to say about that I okay I
can't answer thank you representative
reels you have a comment yes thank you
Mr chairman um I I respect um the point
that representative Harrington is making
but I ask wasn't the 180
days deadline in the bill that we
considered this morning considered the
maximum time that Dees would be allowed
to have to to issue a permit and the
point of this bill including 120 days is
that we're trying to give some urgency
to these repurposing so I don't really
see that it's
inconsistent I see representative
Harrington's
point so at this point I think we're
looking for a
fix um representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair um I believe
the bill we passed recent just today
about on the air permits uh included the
an exception for or didn't really
include Title Five permits for um for
air for air emissions and I might be
mistaken but I think most power plants
and most wood burning plants would be
looking for a Title 5 permit because of
the amount because of the type of
emissions they they um they are they are
emitting and so that's uh you know
something that that comes under the
federal Clean Air Act and we don't know
the timeline for that so and you know
when I'm looking at this I think that
the uh perfect shouldn't be the enemy of
the good and we should just go with the
builtin Escape valve if you will of
requiring the applicant to you
know ask for an ex an
extension good point we didn't um adopt
449 this morning we just heard it but
but I think you're right about Title
Five representative
muns uh thank you Mr chair um I I wasn't
going to bring these up because they're
really not significant but um if we were
to consider
um a change uh an additional Amendment
um there is a there is a typo on line
one on page one line
15 uh that we might want to fix um the
modified energy facility would either I
think there's we need a b there be be
permitted um so that's one minor issue
and then on page
five this is a little bit more sub
substantive again I don't know that it's
what I would consider something to hold
up the amendment if everybody is
comfortable with everything else but at
the top of the
page um we talk about a public
information session in the city or town
where the particular case is um
pending uh which is something we had
talked about during um our work session
um and so we made the change there so
that the meeting in the county would be
in the town where the that that's most
affected we made the change at the top
of line five in lines two and three but
we did not make the
change um at the bottom of the
page uh where we also talk about a
public Hearing in the in each
County so again if we were going
to request an additional amendment to
address other concerns i' want to have
us try to fix that as
well does that make sense Yes except
where at the bottom of the page uh p uh
P bottom of page five line 33 where it
says that site the site evaluation shall
hold at least one public Hearing in each
County oh in in which the proposed
facility is to be located and the idea
was to have it be in the town in the
county where the facility was located we
did it up top but we didn't do it at the
bottom but I don't want to be the sole
reason for an amendment I have a
question on that yes representative
Harrington yeah can someone explain to
me what this means that dropped sentence
there on uh page five says at Le least
one public information session in each
city or town in the case of a purposing
and otherwise in each County what is
repurposing in a case of a purposing is
what mine says I don't know what that
means it should be
repurposing repos because purposing
doesn't make any sense
there I
mean I don't know what purposing is a
facility Mr
chair can I can I try to address that
you can help by all means I can't you're
I you know I hadn't caught that I mean
you're right it should say repurposing
the the in I know the intent was that
that that the that the required
information session to be held in the
county of the proposed facility would be
in the town where that facility was
located that was the intent now I don't
know if maybe the wording could be
cleaned
up actually L 26 on page five also talks
about a
purposing the actual term is defined is
a qualified repurposing so maybe that's
the term we should be using throughout
the bill if you look on line five on
page one that's
defined in fact on page one starting on
line seven and going to page two through
line four that's all new text that was
added to the amend to this amendment to
clarify just exactly what qualified
repurposing
means so that's one of the more
important parts of this amendment is
that
text that uh I just outlined from seven
on page one to four on page
two through four on page two
all right so it sounds to me like maybe
we need to do to U do some more work on
this amendment before we move
forward or we could move forward
representative Corman thank you um I
also just find the amendment as written
unclear that uh it does apply to a
qualified repurposing so if you look at
page two line 7 the heading for 162 h7a
says say qualified existing energy
facilities repurposing but nowhere else
in here does it say that all this
procedure applies only to qualified
repurposing it's just listed in the
header it doesn't say these things apply
to repurposing and then when you get to
um page five line 26
1B it says except in the case of a
qualified repurposing so apparently
there's something about when there isn't
a qualified repurposing so it seems to
be a bit mixed up about what's applying
when so would you be advocating that the
word repurposing be inserted before the
word
application on
lines
10 and
Below um which page page two page two
so instead of saying upon filing of an
application it would say upon filing of
a repurposing
application or qualified repurposing
application well I mean the the the
issue I have here is if you look at line
eight of that page it says all
applications for a certificate for an
energy
facility so it's not saying it's not
restricting it only to the
qualified right I think we need
something that says section
7A applies to qualified
repurposing yeah qualified ex yeah I I
take your point yeah I think I think it
just needs to say that and then and then
of course what I said about on page five
where it says except in the case of a
qualified repurposing so why are we
saying accept in the
case Mr
Mahan could I ask you you
to come up to the microphone and let us
know whether you think such clarifying
language is necessary here um I don't
have a copy of the amendment that you're
working with so we can get you
one this is this is essentially the the
text that yeah and I and I'll jump right
into I
think um RSA going from memory here but
it got chilled in my head last week the
uh is it 162
h7a uh is a new section right so it only
applies to the qualified
repurposing so
um so what representative Corman is
suggesting is that maybe we need a new
section one that says the following
applies only to qualified repurposing
just for for clarity
I think yes I think for clarity purposes
that makes sense I don't know that it's
necessary but again I don't have I'm
looking at this version for the first
time the intention was that uh 162 h7a
only applied to the qualified
repurposing um
track but given the fact that 162 H is a
an extremely long and and complicated
RSA MH to eliminate the possibility that
the FastTrack
section and the regular section don't
get confused maybe it's worthwhile to
point out that this applies only to the
fast track no I think perfectly fine and
as we've said from the beginning we want
to make sure that the sub evaluation
committee has as much guidance as
possible so I think that that would
that's a very helpful
change okay thank you and and I would
say in that case when we go back to page
five line 26 where we have this bolded
language except in the case of a
qualified purposing which maybe should
be repurposing do we even need that if
the the assumption is that everything in
7A is about qualified
repurposing yeah except that by the time
you get to that text on page five line
26 now you're in a different section of
the RSA now you're in RSA 162
h10 right so oh so maybe that text does
need to stay there good point thanks y
okay so applies only to
qualifying okay further comments from
the
committee representative Corman yeah so
uh given that when I look at uh page
four um starting on line 4 162
h7b role of state
agencies that section applies to all
site evaluation not just the FastTrack
ones is that correct
think the same any clarification on that
uh rep Mr Monahan I'm looking back at uh
Dave Dave maybe if Dave shulok joined me
because we worked in this language yes
Mr shulock could you come up
please and I'm just a little hesitant to
jump right into an answer because I
don't have the full Statute in front of
me so yeah it's a little hard seeing it
today even in right we his the question
is on page four beginning in line four
we're talking about the role of state
agency is that is just for the
FasTrack provisions of the new
law no
okay 162
h7b would apply to
everything so so so then the fast track
is really only
7A and the definitions
that's correct and then um the
definition and then some of those minor
changes that you see in 162 h10 right
and there is a difference between notice
notice is given in the town but the
hearing is held in the
county the way that this is written
right and that is um it's written it can
be changed I'm not saying it can't be
changed but the reason that it's written
that way uh is because that section does
apply to all hearings
uh which would include transmission
hearings and sometimes those
transmission facilities span multiple
municipalities and it's inefficient to
have that in just in every town as
opposed to in the county where most of
those municipalities are likely located
you know Mr chair could I could I
address that yeah representative M um I
I understand what you're saying and and
I certainly wasn't arguing that we'd
want to have a um Hearing in every town
the whole reason for having it in the
town where the repurposed facility or
the facil is located is it just makes it
more convenient for the people that are
most affected to be able to get
there that that's that's the whole
reason right
and that fix could probably be drafted
it's just not in there
currently yeah certainly you unfort you
have to distinguish between what this is
mostly about which is facility an
existing facility in one town and one
location I understand where you'd need
the ability for pipeline or transmission
line to be the
county Mr shulock mentioned
transmission let's assume
that National Grid sold their existing
transmission line that runs through the
state to a different company and that
company wanted to
repurpose that transmission line to I
don't know threat Curr what DC yeah
direct
current uh would that require site
evaluation committee uh approval to do
that and is that would that be covered
by this repurposing
statute I don't have the statute here in
front of me there are it would depend on
the length of the transmission line all
all sorts of
variables okay well something worth
considering I guess all right
representative
Ms sorry if I opened up a Pandora's Box
um I have a a question um on
page on on page two um line three uh one
of the one of the elements of the
definition of of a qualified repurposing
is that the applicant demonstrates that
the modification may result in
qualitative improvements in the health
and safety of the state or the system
reliability in New Hampshire I guess I
have two questions about that one is how
do how do you demonstrate
that um and then the second uh question
is um can you demonstrate that before
the fact or do you have or is a
demonstration after the fact I mean you
don't really
know what's going to
happen so I I guess my my my first
question was do we need to be a little
bit more specific in terms of what
demonstrate
means so I
think yeah this was among all the
parties who worked on this language this
was an important part to be included I
think it's important that understand
this is part of the application to make
it into the FastTrack process but then
when you look at the five-part criteria
that the site evaluation committee has
has to use to approve everything it
includes a more substantial
consideration of the issues around
public health and safety Financial
managerial things like that so um uh
just just like everything else in the
application you need to during the
process once it's filed is you need to
demonstrate that it's true and accurate
and representative Summers has a
question just a quick question um just
because of confusing going back and
forth should there be a defined
definition of what is part of this
amendment is in Fast trck and what is
throughout all in including
FasTrack yeah we we kind of addressed
that a moment ago when we talked about
adding
online8 a new section one that says that
this section H7 hon
7-a applies only to qualified repurpose
ing
applications it's kind of hard looking
at this amendment to realize that this
is part of RSA 162 which right now is
about I forget how many pages 30 pages
long
so taking this out of context of of that
that larger
picture is a little
confusing so
and I and I'm not saying that you're
confused I'm saying it could be
confusing to all of us but so but but a
75 page Amendment would have been
equally confusing yeah 75 page Amendment
would have been really confusing so all
right further representative
Harrington getting back to what was just
mentioned there I I I I tend to agree
that we need and that's on line three of
page two the applicant demonstrates the
modification may result in qualitative
Improv mement the health and safety of
the state or to system reliability in
New Hampshire far Fest case but let's
say someone repow a wood burning plant
with coal now that may add to the system
uh reliability of New Hampshire but it's
probably not going to add to the health
and safety of the state so you could do
one without the other so the way this is
written you'd only have to qualify for
one so you could reduce the uh system
reliability in New Hampshire as long as
you made improvements to health and
safety
or you could increase the system
reliability regardless of what effect
you had on self health and safety I
think that statement is way too vague in
it's an either or you can meet one of
two requirements you don't have to meet
both so how about if we change the word
or to and improvements to the health and
safety of the state and to system
reliability it's that's an improvement
for sure but it's it's still it's a very
vague Loosely defined term on health and
safety and system reliability there is
no formula you pushing into and say
count out the crank oh yeah the system
of reliability went from 8.4 to 8.5 so
we've improved it and the health and
safety went from 3.0 to 3.6 we've
improved it it's it's totally arbitrary
is what it's in the eye of the beholder
I guess Mr manahan you said that this
line was important to some of the
stakeholders could you elaborate on
that uh yeah I think that uh there were
as the committee may know there were
some folks that were concerned that were
were advocating that this change only
applied to facilities that were going to
repower without repow with um renewable
or clean energy um I felt as though and
I think most of the people that worked
on that felt that that was a didn't
belong there because this this
essentially a land use spill and
anything that deals with emissions
belongs in another part of state law and
so the um suggestion that would that I
think I made was to use health and
safety but I didn't make that up
uh those are requirements that are
already exist in other parts of the
citing law and so it's a uh we're
repeating what already exists and I
apologize I don't have the whole RSA 162
in front of me but it seemed to be that
because it had existed in state law and
and I'm sure even commissioner
Harrington at the time when is sitting
on some site evaluation committee things
there was probably a provision that is a
part of the review there was a review of
the health and safety
so MH y if I may add yeah yes go ahead
the language or contributes to system
reliability uh that was added by the
department so um because the department
views the bill as technology neutral
right
um we understand that everything that's
on the table for the coming years is
most likely renewable and it's most
likely not wood because it's not
economic right and uh we don't really
see anybody trying to uh repower or with
coal or some or wood with coal or
something like that um it was actually
added there to try and make it easier
for Battery Systems to show some
contribution uh to be to be able to get
FASTT tracked but um if the sponsors of
the bill believe that they can make a
showing under health and safety for
those batteries uh the
department would withdraw that request
right
uh yeah representative McGee I would
just respond to that and say I I don't
think you should I think it's there
purposefully I think the idea is that if
you have a consideration for reliability
in there then it means that the projects
are going to be considered in that way
which means they may end up having that
storage component or another piece so so
it's saying we want we want to consider
both right we want we want to make sure
that the projects provide those things
in the best case scenario so I think the
language should
stay again I know I mentioned this
before but this the section what we're
referring to is simply what's in the in
the application and then the application
has to be proven with expert testimony
and and Witnesses and things like that
so yeah thanks representative Harrington
but my problem is again it's it's an
either or situation and I think you want
both if that's the intent of this is
that it and also got May and if you're
saying you've got to back it up with
proof and everything we shouldn't be
using the word may because May means it
may show it it may not it's not a
requirement so you should say the
applicant demonstrates that the
modification will result in a
qualitative Improvement to health and
safety of the state and to system
reliability in New Hampshire if that's
the intent that's the way it should be
written because with a May ites it's not
a requirement it says they may show that
it's being done so it's you know and
again with the or you could pick one and
not the other so I think it definitely
needs to
work do you have a comment on on that
question so um the the purpose for
having the May there um and having it to
be qualitative was to make it easier for
the chair or the administrator of the
SEC to approve or deny a FasTrack
without any sort of litigation or
argument over whether there is an actual
and
quantitative uh benefit to the state so
that applicants don't have to come in
saying that uh we're reducing carbon by
x amount and that's going to result in
why fewer cases of asthma in the town
and is going to save the state X
hundreds of thousands of dollars right
that that they wouldn't have to go
through that type of proof just to
qualify for a faster
track but whether whether whether you do
that that's certainly a policy question
right so if if you want more proof up
front
that's okay representative
reels yeah um again I I understand what
representative Harrington is getting at
but I would I guess refer to the answer
just given and I don't think we want to
make this change from sh from May to
shall
because you're it would be taking a bill
that's intended to facilitate things
happening and now uh raising raising the
bar to you know require all kinds of
data and proof and in this case or with
respect to reliability the state of New
Hampshire is not
the AR you know Department of energy is
not the Arbiter of system reliability
right that's a that's a responsibility
of the regional grid operator so you'd
be you'd be putting a burden on the
department of energy to evaluate
something that it's really not empowered
to to to evaluate representative Corman
thank you I mean I I I I interpret the
May part as saying that there's a
plausible
argument toward the health and safety
and the system reliability and as far as
whether to change or to and I I would be
against that uh just take a simple
scenario where there's no change to the
health and safety but a big change to
reliability I wouldn't want to not allow
that to be fast-tracked because it
doesn't meet the and
and just to take representative
Harrington's scenario of something uh
improves Rel reliability but is uh a
detriment to health and safety maybe it
gets fast-tracked but then later on is
denied because of that so it's not like
we're automatically going to approve it
if it's detrimental to health and safety
we're just fast-tracking the application
and then maybe in fact the denial
happens
sooner okay further discuss
representative licki in the same section
it says demonstrates um expert testimony
or assertions are not a demonstration
turning the thing on and seeing the
actual results is the only thing that
can demonstrate
it well it says the applicant
demonstrates and I think it basically
means the application
demonstrates but once again an
application demonstrates nothing except
paper the application application can
demonstrate intent and can
demonstrate uh with further information
just how it intends to provide the
improvements to health and
safety or system
reliability Mike uh demonstrating intent
is not the same as demonstrating the
actual performance every one of us here
has seen various unintended consequences
um and consequences of things that did
not go according to plan I've spent a
lifetime seeing that kind of thing but
since this is just an application you're
never going to be able to
demonstrate uh performance until after
the application is approved and the
project is built and up and running
all right maybe a different word than
demonstrate com on this
please yes representative McGee um I
think we're you know we're having a
great time here we trying to word Smith
this but if you can demonstrate in the
application that you are putting in a
technology that does not emit replacing
a technology that does emit then you
have demonstrated that you have made an
improvement to health and that is that
is an example that I would use right
that is a qualitative demonstration that
you have lowered the emissions of a
plant and so that is I think what they
mean by it that's what the language
means it doesn't mean that they're going
to come in and give you a demonstration
of the technology they're planning to
implement it means that they're going to
give you some qualitative information
about how the technology is an
improvement as a result of the
repurposing of the
facility that's that's what I think the
intention of the language is not to give
an intent but to say the application is
a place where you can make that
qualitative statement about your
technology representative Harrington I
think we what we need to do here is
first decide what we're trying to say
and I think that would make it a little
bit easier because with the word may
there it's not a requirement that it be
done so the applicant demonstrates the
modification may result in well they can
just say we think this will result
improvements to the health and safety or
reliability of the system I mean I don't
know why we have may um to me that's
something you you could be just like was
just said you put in some type of a
logic we're replacing coal with uh wind
and therefore the emissions will go down
and so that you're showing the health
and safeties being taken care of and
then I still go back to the either or
situation or do you need it at all what
happens if they they don't show that
does that mean it can't be fast-tracked
unless it meets one of those criteria or
both so if it I mean you can certainly
put in something that improves system
reliability that's not going to improve
the health and safety it may not hurt
the health and safety but it's not going
to necessarily improve it so we trying
to say here's two criteria you got to
meet you may have to meet one of them or
you absolutely have to meet one of them
or would be better to put in the
negative and say does not result in
lessening of the health and safety of
the of the state or reliability of the
system in New Hampshire and that would
just prove that would basically say
we're we're not making things worse or
do we have to make things better I don't
think that question is being answered in
this statement it kind of leaves it
hanging it probably means that you have
to meet one or the other or both that's
probably what it means representative
Kennedy uh yeah thanks you know a small
nuclear reactor would increase
reliability and health and safety if it
was replacing a coal plant but the whole
point of this thing is wind and solar
even though those words do not appear
anywhere I mean this is what I said
during the the meeting this this thingss
to want to dance around what the purpose
of this is you repowering I mean that is
ridiculous okay further
comment looks like representative
Kennedy gets the last word on this on
this bill it seems to me that um this
amendment is not ready for prime time at
the moment it needs another draft so I
think that I will um continue this P
this executive session until a future
date certain so keep an eye on your
calendar and we will uh reschedule this
executive session for a future date so
we're going
to uh recess this public hearing uh
executive session on Senate Bill
451 and in the meantime we will try to
create a new Amendment and
representative muns I would like to
enlist
your your Aid in crafting new language
for page five on line
two and three the bolded text which is
really confusing
language and
also for line 33 where that the same
text that you use in line two and three
should go in line 33 so could you help
create new text for that y I'd
appreciate
that and representative McGee and I will
submit to
O um the changes that we have identified
that need to be make made to this
amendment and ask for a new Amendment
which we will
consider the next time we meet an
executive session on this
Bill okay so I'll just feed my language
to the two of you yes please
okay okay now let's move on I'd like to
open an exec session on Senate Bill
540 and I'd like to recognize
representative Bernardi for a
motion I'm moand from
study I recognize representative Kennedy
I second the motion moved in seconded
that we refer Senate Bill 450 for
interim
study 540 sorry 540 for interim study
discussion representative
Bernardi uh yes looking at the bill uh
the great bulk of it discusses utility
scale energy storage that is not the
province of the Department of energy
that's the province of iso New England
uh and and
therefore um only part part of the bill
in my mind appears relevant for any kind
of uh further study which would be that
battery storage or battery
capability uh that would be relevant to
uh uh residential or maybe small
commercial customers um for looking at
what value behind the meter uh um energy
with would be and there's nothing in the
bill that that says what we're going to
do with that information when we get
there so I think it really requires some
kind of of study to see if there's any
value in doing this at
all okay further discussion
representative Corman thank
you I feel that um behind the meter
storage
and utility scale storage are extremely
important to our Energy Future we talk
about reliability being key and storage
is one way that we're going to be
achieving that going forward especially
as we go toward renewable
sources the bill does actually talk
about uh things that can be done I mean
I'm just looking at line 14 how best to
encourage both utility and non-utility
investments in energy storage projects
so it it it can actually result in some
really good ideas that utility and
people like me actually do have
batteries now um Can can actually put
into action um I would also point out
that you know as we think about
batteries uh The Battery Technology of
today is not the Battery Technology
we're going to see in a few years the in
terms of energy it seems that the
fastest technological change is
happening in batteries the batteries
that I just put in my house two weeks
ago are going to be obsolete in a few
years because of the improvements right
it's not going to be lithium ion it's
going to be solid state it's going to be
iron and I think it would be really good
for the for the state to actually be
ahead of this and and be able to
understand where batteries are going so
that we can have reliable storage and
reliable energy so I'm going to be
voting against the motion and I actually
like the
bill okay further
discussion representative McGee thank
you Mr chairman um I I'd have to Echo
what uh my colleague representative
Corman just said and also say that if we
if we um opted to move sp54 forward then
we would not have to move forward
Senator aar's Bill that would be
modified to only storage because it
would be covered I think in some of the
questions that we're asking here that be
um responded to in this department of
energy
investigation um this also goes into
things like regulatory changes and
challenges with the utilities and what
it does is it prompts us to have the
kind of conversations that we need to
have to get to the infr infastructure
changes that would be needed to support
adoption of of renewable energy sources
so so these things are I look at them as
impediments um to the Investments that
people would be making if they had the
answers to those questions so I I really
do think it is it is incumbent upon us
to at least investigate those things and
get those answers so we know uh how to
move forward I I think a lot of the
again impediments um that need to be
removed are in the realm of upcoming
technology and things that we don't
understand and I think this bill covers
both of those and I think we we kind of
owe it to our constituents to get more
knowledge on it so we can make better
bills representative licki thank you Mr
chairman um my personal background is in
the electronics Industry for starting in
1966 and for every part of that time The
Good batteries were always right around
the corner and they still are we've made
incremental improvements we did NAD um
and replaced some lead acid we did
nickel metal hydride was another
technology that was a little bit better
lithium ion is significantly better
however none of them are the revolution
that we've been promised for 60 some
years thank you representative
Kennedy uh thanks Mr chairman I this is
kind of a general question since I'm
still fairly new here is why do we have
to write laws to do something like this
I mean can't somebody just ask the
department of energy to do this I mean
we we seem to write laws I mean the last
thing we were talking about was
basically a law to tell the department
of energy to make a plan to have a plan
I mean you know anyway um so this to me
just looks unnecessary
representative
Harrington yeah well we keep the term
gets used in here quite a bit utility
scale uh I'm not quite sure what's meant
by that but I'm assuming it means
something to do with the utilities so is
this are we going back to the pre
structuring days when now we're going to
have utilities putting up huge uh uh
battery storage facilities and basically
getting back into the generation
business to some extent they going to be
buying power and putting it in there is
the next step they'll be producing their
own power to store their batteries with
and that's a major change in our
philosophy of allowing markets to do
this I think the best people for
pursuing modate Advanced Technologies
are the people willing to spend their
own money on it whether they be private
individuals or the utilities well you
don't need the state to try to steer
them in the right direction because let
be quite honest we don't know exactly
what that direction is someone who de
deals in that business day after day and
knows all the ins and outs of it is the
one I want making those decisions ISS
not not a bunch of people sitting around
their desk in this
room
okay representative
reels thank you Mr chairman um I think
uh representative Kennedy and and
representative Heron can make some some
good points um as well as as my
colleagues representative Corman um and
ranking member McGee but I I think that
the
approach that we need and the department
of energy if we ask them to undertake a
study here they don't need to become
experts they shouldn't actually concern
themselves very much with becoming
experts on technology or Arbiters of
Technology what is good and what is bad
Etc uh what our department of energy and
you know our Public Utilities Commission
have dominion over is the role that
storage may play in uh um enhancing
reliability and decreasing costs for all
rate payers and that would be the the
rules and the
incentives under which energy storage
could play in the New Hampshire Market
that is our responsibility and their
responsibility and I think it would be
useful to have them get up to speed on
things like you know time of use rates
and and
other other aspects of you know the
evolution of the grid and the role that
storage can
play we should get more up to speed on
that we don't need to you know worry
about what the technology is what the
best technology is as representative
Harrington says the market will take
care of that but right now New Hampshire
has sort of
no um we nowhere in terms of inviting
you know innovation in the market um
because those there's no recognition of
storage in our rates or
anything else so that's what I would
say representative
Kennedy yeah as I understand the
department of energy is not a very old
department so I mean does it have a
mission statement or something you know
I I used to think that laws were general
you know you would have a you know a
department or whatever and you know
maybe a few pages about what it is
they're supposed to do and then once in
a while you know I guess you could have
some kind of revie view or whatever but
we seem to want to write down exactly
what we want all these departments to do
you know and and we lack expertise so I
would think that you know the department
I mean I would think if the department
of energy is not doing this kind of
thing then it's not doing its job or we
haven't defined its job well
enough well I'd like to make a few
comments about this bill I see five
major problems with this
bill the first one is it costs $250,000
to rate payers which may not seem like a
lot of money but when you keep adding
250,000 here and 250,000 there and
500,000 there it adds up so I don't
really see that it's appropriate for us
to be adding to what the citizens of New
Hampshire are paying on their electric
bill every year if we can avoid it
secondly as representative Bernardi
mentioned utility scale storage is an
ISO no England concern it's not
something that the state needs to get
involved
with thirdly this bill for ports to
seek out reasons why there are
hurdles for the adoption of energy
storage well it's pretty clear that the
two primary hurdles to the adoption of
energy storage are financing paying for
it and the materials that are used to
build these
things why do we need to study that it's
pretty obvious what the ma major hurdles
are to the adoption of
batteries another reason this bill is
inappropriate it's not government's job
to encourage investments in anything any
kind of Technology it's up to the
private sector the people who are
actually going to finance this stuff
it's up to them to figure out how to
make those investments in a way that
allows them to enjoy some kind of of a
return on their
Investments and then the final thing
that's wrong with this
bill is that it's pretty vague its
requirements are pretty vague on line 14
on page one for example it says how best
to encourage both utility and
non-utility investments in energy
storage projects what does encourage
mean give them a pat on the back give
them a a gold star if they figure
something
out on line 19 and online 21 it uses the
word program but it never
defines what kind of a
program that
uh they want to to
discover practice best practices for or
the implementation of on line seven it
talks about the department shall
investigate ways to
facilitate both behind the meter and
energy and utility scale storage well
facilitation is a public policy and I
don't think it's the
Departments or government's role in
general to be facilitating something
that needs to be done and owned by the
private sector I I think this bill is is
totally unnecessary for those reasons
and
others uh I could go on for a long time
about why this bill is no good and I
think we should just refer it for
interim study and then talk next fall
about whether we actually want to look
at studying this bill but it's not the
kind of Bill that we should be passing
at this point in time
representative
Summers Mr chairman question for you
because of those motion those items that
you had just spoken would it be would I
be out of place to make a motion to
recommend itl for this bill instead of
interim
study we have a motion on the floor of
interim study we would have to vote on
that and see what the outcome was
first so we will do that representative
partiall
you chair and I take every one of your
points very seriously I think they're
very well considered but at the same
time we had House Bill
1465 we got a nice little book out of
that telling us the direction that
nuclear energy should take in the state
and yet much of your criticism doesn't
that apply to that bill
also as far as you know we're not going
to implement it it's out of our Wick to
uh Implement any you don't we're not not
paying for it and that did create a
significant hole in our budget that's in
order to even look at it and it is
technology that is
really not for us to invest in or to
uh 1465 I had to oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
yeah ask representative Bernardi what
bill that was as the nuclear study was a
nuclear one which I have similar
feelings on I would think so I was I was
cu to Garner your opinion on
that well the nuclear study bill uh
didn't uh spend any money that wasn't
already allocated as I
recall so um this bill does spend money
and I object to that among other things
that's a fair objection I would
agree any further comments any further
discussion representative licki um I'd
make a distinction between the nuclear
bill in this bill this bill is
projecting that some kind of storage
that's better than what we have today
will come to exist we've got the seor
nuke we know it puts out power we know
that things have moved a long way since
NE cook came online and so uh you know
on one hand we have the nuclear and I
will agree that there's nothing we can
do to make nuclear come to New Hampshire
however at least we're talking about a
technology that's been
proven further discussion representative
MS
you know ba based on the strong comments
that I've heard on from from both sides
of on this bill uh the pros and the cons
I I don't know that a motion of inim
study is the right motion I I would
agree with representative Summers that
you know um we should uh we should vote
down the interim study motion and then
have a straight up or down vote on this
bill okay okay further discussion
further
comments representative
Bernardi thank you Mr chair uh so uh
sort of piggybacking off of what
representative parall said uh you know
we created a study commission we looked
at nuclear energy um uh you know my
initial uh thought on this bill was itl
because I thought there's really nothing
here in that I believe is going to be of
value coming out of uh this work but I
said all right there are uh there's a
potential for maybe looking at Value
associated with batteries so we in an
interim study group could pull out those
things which are truly under State
Control not ISO New England control and
potentially
uh Advance those efforts but similar to
like the report that was put out on
nuclear we could put out a mini report
or have one done on where what the
status of battery is if if that's an
option going forward hence the motion
for interim study but um you know again
my my thrust would be if left my own
devices i' itl this uh but I want to be
open and inviting to those that think
there's some Merit here to at least pull
out what could be of
Merit representative
Kaplan yeah thank you I have to agree
with representative bernardy I think
there there is potential Merit in
looking at battery storage and and there
might be flaws with this bill uh but I
think the intent is is valuable and if
we are concerned about grid reliability
and I know that's something that we're
concerned with uh we know that battery
storage can help with that we know it's
going to be part of transitioning to
renewable energy and
so there are definitely ways we can look
to make uh our state more amable to
Bringing more of of battery storage on
whether that's behind the meter or
utility scale even though utility scale
is ISO New England um I don't think it's
beyond uh the remit of our department of
energy be looking at ways to bring that
on that's to the benefit of our
constituents so yeah i' would be in
favor of of at least looking at interm
study for
this further
comments okay seeing none I'm going to
ask the clerk to call the role on the
question of the adoption of the motion
of refer for interim study on Senate
Bill
540 Vice chair Thomas yes representative
ner yes representative Harrington yes
representative licki yes representative
Melvin yes yes representative Bernardi
yes representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee no representative
MC Williams no Representative parshall
no representative Kaplan yes
Representative muns no representative
Noel no representative Thomas
no representative Corman no
Representative rolds no chairman of O
yes two three four five six seven eight
nine 10 11 two one two three four five
six seven eight 11 to
eight okay by I vote 11 to8 the motion
to refer for interim study on Senate
Bill 540 is
adopted and representative Bernardi will
write the calendar report will there be
a minority reports representative
McGee I would like to write
representative Corman will write The
Minority
Report and if you could have that ready
for us before you leave today that would
be
appreciated okay uh with that we'll
close the exec session on House Bill uh
Senate Bill 54 Zer and that brings us to
the close of our business for today I'd
ask you all to reserve next Monday the
22nd of April for a committee session it
will likely be a
an executive session maybe a work
session and an executive session on the
four bills that we heard earlier today
plus we still have work to do on Senate
Bill
451 so keep next Monday the 22nd open
representative Thomas are we goingon to
meet in the
morning yes yes we we will start in the
morning yes I'm GNA need us anybody else
have anything they would like to discuss
with the committee before we go
representative
Summers use your mic
please next week is uh school vacation
week for the State of New Hampshire in
case anybody conflicts with anybody
that's all I was going
say all day okay I'll try to remember
that but probably still going to
schedule a committee meeting that day so
if you could work that into your school
vacation plans that would be appreciated
okay anything
else it's Earth day as well that's true
all right thanks everybody we'll see you
next week